Herzlich Willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 8.
Mit Geschichten von Geheimdiensten und aus dem Kalten Krieg und von vorher.
Und heute haben wir zum ersten Mal einen Gast dabei in Alternativlos, der seinen Namen nicht nennen möchte.
Doch.
Wie doch? Plötzlich doch?
Je nachdem, ob es gut wird.
Genau, wir schneiden das raus.
Wir schneiden den Namen dann später raus. Also wie ist dein Name?
Markus Kompas ist mein Name. Abruflich bin ich Anwalt. Mein Studium habe ich mit Zauberkunst finanziert und ich war schon als Kind immer fasziniert von Tricks, illusionen und so weiter. Und vor einigen Jahren habe ich mich dann mehr mit politischen Geheimnissen und politischen Täuschungsgünsten beschäftigt. Und deshalb sitzen wir heute hier, nämlich Geheimdienste und Tricks, die eben in diesen Bereichen da angewendet werden.
Ja, also wir haben uns überlegt, wir fangen mal mit einem kleinen Witz an. Nämlich, welches ist denn der beste Geheimdienst der Welt?
Da fallen einem so einige ein, ne?
Ja, so Mozart, CIA, NSA. Und ich wollte jetzt die position vertreten, dass Dänemark den besten Geheimdienst hat.
Basierend auf der Theorie, dass man von denen noch nie gehört hat, oder wie? Genau, das ist doch der perfekte Geheimdienst, oder?
Die Niederlande haben ihren Geheimdienst abgeschafft. Das ist vielleicht die größere politische Leistung.
Bei dem Auslandgeheimdienst? Inländisch sind die eher...
Also der inländische Geheimdienst ist noch eher sehr aktiv und ziemlich unterwegs. Die waren ja neulich, hatten wir die erwähnt. Haben wir gerade in der letzten Sendung zu Wilders erwähnt, dass die sich darüber beschwert haben, dass der über eine israelische Botschaft geht zum Konferieren und sie ihn da nicht abhören können. Also der holländische Geheimdienst, man macht ja noch so andere interessante Dinge. Also die wurden ja zum Beispiel auch notorisch, als es damals um die Wahlcomputer ging. Und dann brauchten sie jemanden, der feststellen kann in den Niederlanden, ob denn jetzt diese Wahlcomputer elektronische Abstrahlung haben. Und da stellte sich dann heraus, dass diejenigen, die da die Expertise hatten, war halt der AIWD, also der holländische Geheimdienst. Und die haben dann halt mal angefangen zu messen. Da gab es da dieses, irgendwo liegt da dann so ein Report oder wurde mündlich kolportiert. Die haben dann halt diesen einen Wahlcomputer da eingemessen und haben dann festgestellt, naja, wir haben das auf so einer großen Militärbasis gemacht.
Der eine fiel irgendwie sofort aus dem Rest heraus, oder?
Ja, die Abstrahlung davon war so stark, dass sie sich auf der Basis nicht so weit weg davon bewegen konnten, dass sie sie nicht mehr empfangen konnten. Das war so diverse 100 Meter, weil die haben sie dann sofort abgeschafft. Die waren noch vor den NEDAPs. Also das war die SDU.
Lustigerweise ist ja auch einer unserer Kritikpunkte an den NEDAPs am Ende Abstrahlung gewesen, wo man eigentlich gedacht hätte, also wenn wir das messen können, können wir das eigentlich auch. Aber das ist so ein roter Faden, der sich durch die Geheimdienste durchzieht, sodass man eigentlich deren Kompetenz immer ganz gut verschätzt.
Naja, also die Abstrahlung von den NEDAPs haben die auch schon gesehen. Das war ja nicht so, dass es überhaupt nicht sichtbar war. Der war nur sehr viel geringer als die von diesen STU-Dingern.
Naja, aber ich meine, trotzdem, du kannst irgendwie ein paar Meter weiter sehen, also außerhalb des Wahlbüros.
Ja, das hat der IWD in seinem Bericht aber auch geschrieben. Ach so, okay. Also man kann das halt nur mit einem normalen Empfänger, normalen Amateurfunk-Empfänger oder Scanner empfangen.
Peinlich genug.
Da konnte man halt im Display irgendwie hören, was gewählt wurde anhand des Unlauts, der auf dem Display-Controller unterschiedliche Updates verursachte.
Ja, aber zurück zu den Geheimdiensten. Also wir haben uns ja gefragt, die erste Frage, die sich da stellt, das wo kommt eigentlich die Idee her, dass man Geheimdienst braucht? So, wer hat das erfunden?
Ja, also die Monarchien hatten immer so ihre Leute, die Geheimdiplomatie gemacht haben.
Aber es war eher Diplomatie damals. Also es war nicht eine Eidwürde.
Leute abgemeuchelt und das meint es. Ja, natürlich Aufklärung. Also grundsätzlich Aufklärung ist ja was Militärisches, also spionage und so weiter. Und wenn man so will, war der Vatikan immer schon der größte Geheimdienst, denn die hatten aufgrund ihrer missionen und so weiter das größte informationsnetz, dass ja auch die informationen zirkulierten. Und im Vatikan ist wahrscheinlich noch heute, ist es noch so, dass dort die meisten politischen informationen gespeichert sind.
Na die haben ja auch ihren eigenen Geheimdienst, der Opus Dei.
Ja, der Opus Dei ist nicht wirklich ein Geheimdienst. Der Opus Dei ist ja mehr eine Sekte, die eine gute Durchdringung hat in der Gesellschaft.
Na ja, das wird immer so spaßig, werden die immer so als der Geheimdienst des Vatikans bezeichnet.
Na die hatten halt eigentlich noch andere, also die haben auch noch andere organisationen. Also jeder der Orden.
Na die Jesuiten sind ja auch bekannt.
Jeder der großen Orden, die Jesuiten sind natürlich besonders bekannt. Dafür hat natürlich den Zugang zu den entsprechenden Herrschern. Und die katholische Kirche hat dann natürlich noch einen besonderen Vorteil, weil die katholische Kirche hat ja diese Beichte, nicht wahr?
Kein Zufall.
Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass die Machtstrukturen eben durchaus darauf beruhen, wer halt, also welcher Orden jetzt den Beichtvater des jeweiligen Herrschers gestellt hat über viele, viele Jahrhunderte. Und darüber halt dann eben berichten konnte nach Hause, was dann jetzt gerade so den Herrscher da bewegt.
Ja, also Wissen ist Macht. Also das, eigentlich spricht man ja nicht von Geheimdiensten, sondern von Nachrichtendiensten.
Das ist die beschönigende deutsche Beziehung.
Ja gut, aber es geht im Wesentlichen um informationsgewinnung, informationsgeheimhaltung, Verarbeitung, Auswertung und so weiter. Das ist eigentlich fast eher ein journalistisches Business, wenn man so will, aber nochmal was den religiösen Aspekt betrifft, das ist auch ganz interessant und zwar einer der größten Arbeitgeber für religionswissenschaftler und so weiter. Das sind tatsächlich die Geheimdienste, weil die eben wissen wollen, wie ticken eben die Leute in den unterschiedlichen Erdteilen und wie reagieren die aus religiösen Erwägungen, wenn wir jetzt hier irgendwas machen?
Ich will mir hier einen Krieg anfangen.
Hättest du gedacht, dass Geheimdienste mit die größten Arbeitgeber von religionswissenschaften sind?
Ja, die ganzen Politikwissenschaftler müssen ja auch irgendwo bleiben. Die Lobbyisten sind ja irgendwann alle voll.
Oh, na da, die Gefahr sehe ich nicht. Aber es gibt ja diese witzige Geschichte, dass die Geheimdienste, also insbesondere die CIA, in großem Stil Kunstförderung betrieben hat in Westdeutschland. Da gab es auch mal eine schöne fernsehdokumentation zu.
Ja, Germany Made in USA heißt sie, glaube ich. Da geht es darum, dass die Amerikaner nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg eben Programme hatten, um den Deutschen die Demokratie näher zu bringen. Interessanterweise haben die auch linke Künstler gesponsort, also alles verdeckt oder größtenteils verdeckt. Wobei, wer wollte, konnte diese lobby-organisation schon durchschauen. Ja, kann man zustehen, wie man will. Tatsache ist, dass die Amerikaner damals in der deutschen Medienlandschaft sehr viel kontrolliert haben in den 50ern und bis in die 60er wohl noch.
Also ich hab mal einen Galeristen getroffen, einen West-Berliner Galeristen, der in den 70ern und 80ern da sehr intensiv unterwegs war. Und der erzählte mir, dass es ein ziemlich offenes Geheimnis war, dass es da einen ziemlich festen Geldbetrag gab, so einige 10.000 Mark im Monat, die von der CRE verteilt wurden unter den Galeristen, die junge, abstrakte, völe Künstler gefördert haben. Und das stammte wohl aus so einem Programm, mit dem die einfach sozusagen die Freiheit des Westens plakativ darstellen wollten. Also einfach den, ja, also alles, was gut und schön ist am Westen, halt also Meinungsfreiheit und Kunstfreiheit und Äußerungsfreiheit und wir könnten wild und freaky sein, das haben sie halt damit gefördert. Und die haben sich dann natürlich den größten Teil in die Nase gezogen und damit halt dann umso buntere Bilder gemacht.
Na, das ist auch so ein Gegenprogramm, die Nazis mit ihrer entarteten Kunst.
Also ich finde es ja durchaus positiv. Also meine stille Hoffnung ist ja eigentlich, dass der Westen irgendwann versteht, dass das eigentlich seine Chance gegen China sein wird. Nämlich wenn die Chinesen halt anfangen mit starker Meinungskontrolle und starker Kunstkontrolle, was sie vermutlich zwangsläufig im Quantum werden, dann wäre das halt natürlich ein sehr vielversprechendes und aus meiner Sicht begrüßendes Gegenprogramm des Westens, wenn sie dann halt einfach mal wieder drauf kommen würden, dass irgendwie der ganze Unsinn, den sie jetzt irgendwie wegen 9-11 angefangen haben, also mit irgendwie Denkverboten und dergleichen Dingen mehr, den halt wieder einzudämmen und zu sagen, wir sind ein leuchtendes Vorbild hier für die Welt und versuchen nicht irgendwie die Chinesen nachzumachen.
Das war eigentlich eine der wenigen wirklichen Erfolgsgeschichten der CIA, diese Sache mit radio Liberty und so weiter, dass man einfach eben die amerikanische Kultur über den eisernen Vorhang beachte.
Ja, auch Rias, ne?
Ja, klar, das war halt Musik. funktioniert halt schon Kunst als Transportmedium für Freiheit. Ist halt sehr effektiv so. Und insofern, das ist eine Sache, da kann man wenig gegen sagen.
Auch in die andere Richtung übrigens. Es gab neulich so einen sehr schönen Dokumentarfilm, wie die DDR raubkopierte US-Kunst dann in einem Gegensender gespielt hat, um quasi dem Westen zu demonstrieren, dass es das auch in der DDR gibt. Und die haben halt, also während der Rias noch warten musste, bis sie die offizielle lizenzierte Kopie von der Schallplatte jemals hatten, hat der Osten die halt über irgendwelche Kanäle da drin geschmuggelt und hat sie dann in ihrem radio auf dem Brocken gespielt.
Das war doch der Soldatensender sowieso, hieß der.
Ja, genau. Und die haben auch so komische versteckte Botschaften dann irgendwie gesendet.
Und den durfte man...
Nur als Fnord haben diese Sachen gesagt wie 23, bitte 42.
Und der Hammer war, den durften natürlich die Soldaten im Osten nicht hören.
Natürlich nicht, wo kann man denn hin?
Also da hieß es zwar Soldatensender und war halt sozusagen darauf ausgeregt, ja, für die Soldaten so ein bisschen leichte Unterhaltung und so. Und also wie, genau so wie die entlang dem Programm der alliierten Sender, die halt für die Truppen hier waren, das halten nun umgekehrt mit ein bisschen Propaganda drinnen. Und den durften die aber natürlich in der nationalen Volksarmee, weil der halt verboten durfte, nicht gehört werden. Also gab auch nur begrenzte Bereiche, wo überhaupt zu empfangen war, weil dann halt vom Brocken, aber...
Also es gab diese wunderbare Anekdote, dass die eben teilweise auch, wenn sie irgendwelche westoperationen aufgedeckt hatten, dass sie dann so Andeutungen und Details eben auf diesem Sender ausgestrahlt haben, so als Stinkefinger in Richtung Westen. Ja, so, ach, übrigens schön Gruß an Herrn Sohn, so in Daunthalig. Schon durchaus eine sehr humoristisch wertvolle aktion, die wir da gemacht haben.
Verstehe. Na ja gut, ich war für alle eigene Werte von humoristisch, ne?
Ach na ja, was denn? Ich mein, das find ich doch lustig. Ist doch viel besser, als wenn sie Bomben bauen damit.
Ja gut, ich meine, die Geschichte Geheimdienstes ist natürlich vermutlich irgendwie zusammenfallend mit der Geschichte von überhaupt politischen Strukturen, die zuerst entstanden sind. In der Bibel gibt es ja auch schon allerhand Leute, die da rumspionieren und...
Ja, also Geheimdienste, so wie man sie heute kennt, die sind ein Phänomen, das sich so Anfang des Zwanzigjährhunderts entwickelt hat. Interessant ist die Entstehungsgeschichte des britischen Geheimdienstes. Und zwar, es gab da einen damals sehr populären Autoren, der hieß William Lequeuil, oder wie der sich ausspricht, Lequex geschrieben. Kannst du das aussprechen? Naja, und das war also ein Autor, der sogar der Lieblingsautor der Queen gewesen sein soll. Und der hat eben einen Roman geschrieben, Spice of the Kaiser, also spione des deutschen Kaisers. Die Deutschen hatten tatsächlich einen Auslandsnachrichtendienst gegründet, aber jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwie...
Der war noch keine ernste Bedrohung zu der Zeit.
Nein, die haben informationen gesammelt, also völlig unspektakulär. Und dieser Lequex hat eben Lequeuil, der hat in seinen Romanen eben dann wirklich Verschwörungstheorien ausgegeben ohne Ende. Und es war sehr erfolgreich. Und es erhob sich eben so ein großes Geschrei, wir brauchen jetzt auch einen Geheimdienst.
Und es wurde sozusagen hip, ja.
Ja.
Und dann haben...
Na das ist halt per an, wie heute Werbung funktioniert. Wenn in der Bevölkerung klar genug machst, dass man es jetzt braucht, dann braucht man das.
Also diese Spice of the Kaiser würde man heute übrigens Terroristen nennen. Das nur vom Mechanismus her.
Stimmt, die Grenze zwischen Sabotage und informationsgewinnung war noch sehr fließend.
Ja, und jedenfalls, weil also die deutschen spione so gefährlich waren, baute man dann einen Geheimdienst auf. Anfangs noch mit sehr geringem Personal. Allerdings, das hat es in sich. Und zwar der erste Leiter des britischen Auslandsgeheimdienstes, der nicht militärisch war. Der Leiter war schon ein Militär, ein ehemaliger. Das war ein gewisser Mansfield Smith Cumming. Und das war also jemand von der Marine, der irgendwann festgestellt hat, dass er seekrank ist. Und der war auch sonst nur so eingeschränkt verwendungsfähig, denn der hatte beim Unfall sein Bein verloren und sah halt eben ein Holzbein. Und der Mensch muss also sehr skurril gewesen sein. Wenn er also Gäste hatte, die nichts von seinem Holzbein wussten, trug der normales Rosenbein da drüber und hat dann einfach ein Messer genommen und durch das Rosenbein in sein Holzbein gerammt. Einfach nur, um die Leute zu erschrecken.
Schreien sich schon mal very British, sehr spredig. Genau die Art von Personen, die man an der Führung eines Geheimdienstes haben will.
Das ist aber tatsächlich fortgesetzt. Ja, genau.
Solche Leute zieht der Geheimdienst irgendwie an, wie Disney die Motten. Was hat der noch alles gemacht? Der hatte ein Büro gehabt in Whitehall, also in London, in dem Warministerium und so weiter, das versteckt war hinter einer vorgetäuschten Backsteinwand. Da musste man so einen Hebel bewegen, der entfohre die Wand auf. Die Wand hat für überhaupt keinen Nutzen.
Das Büro finden die nie, wenn die rufend kommen und das Haus einnehmen.
Aber der Mensch, der ist auch in Whitehall, da sind da so riesige Gänge und der ist mit so einem Roller gefahren, hat sich immer demonstrativ mit seinem Holzbein abgestoßen.
Ist doch doof, wenn du mit einem Bein durch die Gegend kumpelst, dann nimmst du lieber einen Roller, kann ich verstehen.
Ja, aber stell dir das mal vor.
Das ist doch super, ich find's irgendwie super. Das sind so zwei rote Fäden, die sich ein bisschen durch die Geheimdienstgeschichte ziehen. Also auf der einen Seite, dass so aktionen losgetreten werden aufgrund von dem Einfluss von irgendwelchen Büchern oder Hollywood. Das war ja bei der CIA später diese Missile Crisis, war ja auch totaler Bullshit und hat sich halt so selbst irgendwie hochgewiegelt. Da war nichts reales hinter. Aber so aus aus Furcht heraus sind eben Sachen dann eben doch zu begründen plötzlich.
Das interessante ist ja der amerikanische Kriegsgeheimdienst, OSS, den die Anfang der 40er aufgemacht haben, ist exakt mit der gleichen Verschwörungstheorie begründet worden. Man hat nämlich damals gesagt, es sind deutsche spione an der Westküste und die sabotieren die Schiffe. In Wirklichkeit gab es zwar Saboteure, das waren allerdings britische Geheimagenten, die eben amerikanische Schiffe sabotierten, die die Deutschen unterstützten. Und jetzt dreht man die Story genau um und sagt, da sind deutsche Saboteure, heute würde man sagen Terroristen, also wir brauchen einen Geheimdienst. Und wupps, wurde das OSS gegründet.
Parallel dazu gab es ja die Entwicklung mit den Abhörgeheimdiensten, also mit den Black Chambers, die ja auch sehr früh angefangen haben, Post abzufangen und Post zu lesen und deren Struktur ja auch einen großen Einfluss darauf hatte, wie dann am Ende die Struktur des Postwesens war. Dass es also eine zentralisierte Poststruktur gab, zum Beispiel in Frankreich und auch in England und in Deutschland später, hingen halt schlicht damit zusammen, dass die sie wollten, dass die abzufangen, also dass man halt die Post abfangen kann. Und das ging dann so weit, dass in etlichen Ländern man eine Lizenz brauchte, um einen Botendienst zu betreiben, also ein organisiertes Botenwesen. Und dass es bei Strafe verboten war, Nachrichten zu transportieren, also dass zu Kriegszeiten häufiger vorkommen, also in verschiedenen europäischen Ländern, dass es bei Strafe verboten war, Nachrichten für jemand Drittes zu transportieren. Du durftest als Kaufmann zwar sozusagen für deine Kompagnonsachen mitbringen, aber nicht zum Beispiel für dessen Kompagnon. Und wenn, dann musstest du die öffnen und vorlegen. Und Nachrichten zu schmuggeln, war dann eine Zeit lang ein großes Business. Und das setzte sich dann natürlich fort im Ersten Weltkrieg, als den Yardley, die die erste American Black Chamber gegründet hat, wo sie dann angefangen haben, die Telegrafenfirmen zu überreden, ihnen die Telegramme zu überlassen. Und dann haben sie die nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg wieder aufgelöst. Weil irgendwie mit dem berühmten Satz halt Gentleman, don't read it, it's yours, mayne. Und haben ihn dann natürlich im Zweiten Weltkrieg wieder aufgemacht. So parallel dazu, zu genau dieser OSS. Geschichte von Donovan.
Was ich ja sehr beeindruckend finde, war das schon die CAA, doch die CAA oder NSA, die hatten irgendwann angefangen, Briefkontrolle zu machen im Kalten Krieg. Und hatten das irgendwie so eingerichtet, dass die also nachts gemacht wurde. Und das alles irgendwie so war, dass am anderen Morgen in den Postbehörden und so weiter, alles wieder so war, wie es am Abend verlassen wurde. Es sollte also immer plausible deniable sein.
Das heißt, die hatten zwar einen Schlüssel für das Postbüro, sind da halt rein und haben es...
Es muss ein unglaublicher logistischer Aufwand gewesen sein und es soll auch funktioniert haben.
Also kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Im Osten ließ es halt so, dass die... Wir hatten ja auch zentralisierte Postämter. Und da gab es dann halt einfach hier halt so einen Raum nebenan, wo die Post immer durchging. Also bevor die halt in die Zustellungen kamen, wurden die vorsortierten... Also die haben natürlich dann Monitoring gemacht auf der Basis von Postlerzahlen. Das heißt also, sie hatten Listen, aus welcher Postlerzahl wird welche Zieladresse überwacht. Dann wurden jeweils die aus den Postlerzahlen, dann nachdem die in die Fächer sortiert wurden für die Zustellung der Postlerzahlen, wurden die dann da wieder rausgezogen und in den vorsortiert in diesen Raum gebracht, sodass also auch die Leute in der Post, also die eigentlichen Postler nicht wussten, welche Briefe davon betroffen waren. Die durften die schon einmal vorsortieren nach Postlerzahlen. Dann wurden sie einmal durch diesen Raum geschleift. Da wurden sie über Dampf geöffnet, also die Briefe, die sie halt sehen wollten, und die anderen wieder rausgeholt. Natürlich wurde speziell die Post aus dem Westen intensiv überwacht und die Post in den Westen.
Das hat sich ja als Prinzip weiter erhalten bis heute. Also wenn man sich heute die Abhörschnittstellen, die automatisierten Abhörschnittstellen für Telefone anhört, da gibt es auch das Prinzip, dass die Telco nicht mitkriegen darf, wenn die Polizei abhört. Und wenn ein Geheimdienst einen Polizisten abhört, dann darf die Polizei das natürlich nicht mitkriegen. Also es gibt so eine Hierarchie von, wer alles nicht mitkriegen darf, was die nächste höhere Abteilung macht. Also das Prinzip, das macht ja auch sehr nicht meint, das ist ja...
Also in der technischen spezifikation ist es egalitär ausgelegt. Das heißt, dass bis zu fünf, also jetzt bei modernen Telefonabhörern, dass bis zu fünf institutionen abhören können müssen, ohne dass eine andere institution davon was mitbekommt. Und natürlich der Tele-Tech oder der ISP ohnehin nicht. Das ist halt so der Standard dabei. Aber wir waren eigentlich bei der US-Essen schon...
Moment, eine Sache möchte ich noch machen, wenn wir schon bei Postabhören sind. Da fällt mir nämlich eine Geschichte ein von Mitte letzten Jahres. Da ist nämlich rausgekommen, dass die Westalliierten völlig hemmungslos alles abgehört haben, die Post geöffnet haben und dass es sogar vom Umfang her vergleichbar bis höher war, was die Ostler abgehört haben. Und es gab im Westen immer die Legende, naja, wenn euer Brief geöffnet wurde und so, das war die Stasi, und es haben alle im Westen geglaubt. Also, sag ich mal stellvertretend, alle haben sofort angenommen, wenn da irgendwie was manipuliert wurde. Na, das wird der Osten gewesen sein. Aber rückblickend ist das nicht mehr so klar.
Der Brief wurde zweimal geöffnet. Also, die einen hätten sich ja die Arbeit sparen können, der eine öffnet, der andere versteht.
Da hätte man Synergieeffekte nutzen können, würde man heute sagen. Ja, aber das war richtig, richtig lustig, weil nämlich das Grundgesetz, wenig vorausschauend von den Amerikanern, so gemacht worden war, dass drin steht, Post darf nicht geöffnet werden. Und dann hatten sie ein Problem. Wie öffnet man die Post? Die Lösung im Kalten Krieg war, dass man einfach gesagt hat, das machen nicht wir, das machen die Alliierten. Und dann hat man die Post einmal durch die Alliierten geschleust und die haben die dann geöffnet. Und das war nicht nur die Idee von den Alliierten übrigens, dass wir das so machen sollen, sondern das war Adenauer. Adenauer hat gesagt, na ja, also wir müssen das schon irgendwie öffnen. Was machen wir denn da? Wir können das doch irgendwie mit unseren befreundeten Amerikanern und Briten machen. Und die Franzosen sind auch stark dabei gewesen.
Wie lange hat man das praktiziert? Irgendwann hat es der BND nämlich übernommen.
Irgendwann hat es der BND übernommen. Also ich sehe hier Statistiken bis 1976. Nein, warte mal, 1970 ungefähr. Also irgendwann hat es natürlich übernommen worden, weil wir haben auch einen Geheimdienst gekriegt. Da kommen wir auch gleich zu, wie es eigentlich dazu kommt, dass wir einen Geheimdienst haben. Die Legende. Aber ich will mal dem entgegentreten. Das heißt, der Osten hat immer alles abgehört. Die Briefe sind im Westen genauso geöffnet worden. Macht euch da mal nichts vor.
Tja, wenn man kann, dann tut man es halt.
Natürlich.
Oder wie so schön der Prof. Gusi sagte vor dem Verfassungsgericht, wenn ein Trog da ist, dann kommen die Schweine.
Ist sehr gut.
War sein Kommentar zur Vorratsteilenspeichung.
Nicht schlecht.
Gut, aber wir waren eigentlich bei der OSS, bei der Gründung der CIA, also der vorlauf-aufwesungs-mission.
Also Anfang der 40er-Jahre gab es einen rechtsgerichtlichen General Donovan, das war ein Kriegsheld des ersten Weltkriegs, der Amerika groß rausbringen wollte und wirklich eine Legende war in den USA.
Sein Spitzname war Wild Bill.
Wild Bill Donovan.
Den hat er zu Recht gehabt, der war also bekannt dafür, dass es so ein Cowboy war. Wenn der irgendwas machen wollte, dann hat er das halt gemacht. Er war auch ein Held, deswegen hat man ihn auch machen lassen. Er hat über Jahre das Geheimdienstprogramm der USA praktisch eigenhändig in den Dreck gefahren.
Naja, ich meine, er hätte immerhin was zustande bekommen.
Am Ende war es so schlimm, dass deswegen ist er umgedreht worden in CIA oder umgegründet worden. Nicht nur wegen ihm, aber...
Ja, lange Geschichte. Beginnen wir vielleicht bei der Gründung. Das ist eigentlich eine der kuriosesten Geschichten überhaupt. Die Amerikaner haben eine delegation mit Donovan und ein paar anderen nach London gesandt. Dort sollte der britische Geheimdienst, der jetzt schon einige Jahrzehnte Erfahrung hatte, erst mal mit denen erklären, wie funktioniert es und wie sieht es überhaupt aus. Da hat der britische Geheimdienst eine der größten desinformationsoperationen gemacht. Die haben nämlich praktisch Potemkische Dörfer aufgebaut in Amerikanern, überall gezeigt, wie toll gerade die Kriegswirtschaft funktioniert, wie stark England noch ist, obwohl die halt mit den Deutschen, von den Deutschen schon ziemlich niedergekämpft waren oder jedenfalls bei weitem nicht so stark, wie sie getan haben. Aber sie haben eben die Amerikaner nur an die Schokoladenseiten gefahren. Und das interessante ist, einer der Gastgeber auf der britischen Seite war Ian Fleming. Vormals war das ein Bankier, der aber eben auch ein Marine-Captain war und jetzt war er eben im Geheimdienst. Ian Fleming wurde später bekannt als der Autor der Jims Bond Bücher.
Und der ja durchaus enge Kontakte immer noch hatte zu seinen Geheimdienstkumpels.
Nicht nur zu dem, sondern auch diese britisch-amerikanische Sache, diese Linie wurde von Fleming auch noch lange betreut. Der hat noch Jahrzehnte die Versuche gemacht und so weiter.
Heute würde man sagen, ist wie im Osten, wenn man hört, dass die da ihre Freunde aus Amerika nur an den rufen Stellen vorbeigeführt haben. Das ist exakt, was in der DDR passiert ist. Wenn die Russen kamen, guck mal hier, wie toll das alles ist.
Das war in meiner Geburtsstadt. Wo kommt sie her? Aus Perleberg in Mecklenburg. Ich hab da nie länger gewohnt. Da kam dann irgendwann, ich glaube, Gorbatschow war es vorbei. Das ist eine sehr schöne Altstadt gewesen, mit Fachwerkhäusern und so. Dann haben sie tatsächlich bei diversen Fachwerkhäusern die Fassade saniert, also wirklich präzise die Fassadenwand. Und dahinter also abgestützt mit Balken. Da stand vorne wirklich nur die Wand.
So ein Filmset, ja?
Ja, wie so ein Filmset. Und da haben da Gardinen da reingehängt und Blumenkästen da vorgebaut. Und dann haben sie noch die Wände saniert und gestrichen an der Stadt. Aber nur so hoch, wie man aus dem Autofenster gucken kann.
Also ich hab irgendwann mal gehört, die hätten die Autobahn angemalt, wenn Hornecker irgendwie darum gefahren ist.
Ja, also die Streifen und so haben sie schon immer frisch gemacht. Und da gab es dann halt diesen bizarren Effekt. Das war glaube ich 1986 oder so, als der da war. Und dann rottet der dann halt nach so drei, vier Jahren vor sich hin. Und dann rottet er auch nach der Wende noch weiter vor sich hin. Ich hab da ganz bizare Fotos gemacht, wo dann so langsam die Blumenkästen abrotten. Und die sind irgendwie aus den Gardinen. Da hat sich ein Taub in ein Nest gebaut und so. Und dann blieb er halt alles so. Das sah halt besonders bizarr aus. Aber diese Podiamkinschen Dörfer sind natürlich legendär.
Dazu noch was Interessantes. Der Ian Fleming hat ja auch ein Kinderbuch geschrieben, dieses Chitty Chitty Bang Bang. Und da gibt es auch eben solche illusionen, wo die da so einen Tunnel irgendwie inszenieren. Und in Wirklichkeit ist es ein LKW, und dann fährt das Auto durch den Tunnel und wird vom LKW gecatched. Das sind so diese Art zu denken, der ist halt eigentlich ein Zauber. Ja, Täuschungskunst eben.
Also man kann vielleicht auch, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt einen Zusammenhang gibt, aber die Briten haben ja bis, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren, haben die ihre Schuld bei den Amis abgezahlt für den Zweiten Weltkrieg. Und vielleicht liegt das daran, dass sie eben diese Kampagne gefahren haben, so guck mal, wie gut es uns noch geht und wie schön wir das im Griff haben. Nein, nein, wir brauchen keine Geschenke. Wir leihen uns das. Ich meine, vielleicht ist das ja voll nach hinten losgegangen.
Naja, nee, es war schon so, dass die, also die diesen Landgeschichten waren politisch in den USA auch nicht zu vermitteln, dass es denen geschenkt wird. Also das war nicht, also war ja so, dass die USA bevor Kriegseintritt ja doch durchaus isolationistisch waren. Und also der Krieg, den politisch zu verkaufen, den Kriegseintritt war schon nicht so einfach.
Und da haben die ja glücklicherweise Paul Harbarg für ein Glück gemacht.
Na ja, manchmal hat man auch Glück nicht, oder?
Aber kommen wir noch mal kurz zurück zur Gründung des OSS. Das war ja also der Kriegsgeheimdienst der Amerikaner. Und zwar eben ein von der militärischen Führung unabhängiges Unternehmen war dieses OSS. Das hat den Militärs von Anfang an gestunken. Also diese zivilen Geheimdienste, man nennt sie zivil, weil sie eben nicht in der militärischen Hierarchie sind, obwohl die durchaus militant sind. Und dieser Donovan hatte eben die Idee gehabt, wir brauchen jetzt amerikanische Supersoldaten. Und zwar, der wollte also ganz unkonventionell Krieg führen, so eine Art ninja-organisation. Das heißt, jeder von diesen Supersoldaten sollte also mit Tarnwaffen ausgestattet sein.
Zu viele Supermännchen gewesen, ja?
Genau, den gab es damals noch nicht. Die haben auch dieses Fallschirmspringen kultiviert. Also wenn du heute in die CIA eintrittst, musst du Fallschirmspringen. Obwohl es überhaupt keinen Sinn hat, weil die meisten Leute im Büro arbeiten. Aber das kommt daher, weil die nämlich hinter der Front ihre Leute abgesetzt haben, mit deutscher Kleidung und so, damit sie nicht erkannt werden. Aber sie hatten eben versteckte Messer. Sie hatten also tatsächlich Klingen im Schuh im Absatz, die zwar nicht zum Kämpfen waren, sondern um möglicherweise Fesseln durchzuschneiden und solche Geschichten. Aber sie hatten eben auch Tarnwaffen. Sie haben also mit Schalldämpferpistolen und so weiter ihre Leute ausgerüstet und hatten also wirklich sehr aus heutiger Sicht Hollywood-mäßige Vorstellungen, wie man einen Krieg gewinnen könne. Also der Donovan war halt wirklich der Meinung, dass ein einzelner Soldat von seinen Superleuten besser sei als 100 konventionelle Soldaten.
Na gut, das wird heute bei den Special Forces als Ideologie sich weiter fortsetzen.
Ja, das gab es halt schon vom SIS. Also die Briten hatten solche Sondereinheiten schon immer gehabt. Nicht schon immer, aber sie hatten sie anfangs im zweiten Weltkrieg. Und die Amerikaner dachten, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie noch kreativer sein. Die haben also auch Komiker und so weiter angestellt, um desinformationen irgendwie zu machen. Und dieses OSS hat sich allerdings in zweiten Weltkrieg alles andere als bewährt. Ich müsste jetzt schätzen, aber ein Großteil der Agenten wurde nie wiedergesehen. Ein wirklicher Effekt ist nicht bekannt, außer eben diese...
Also von den operativen Einsätzen.
Von den operativen Einsätzen. Was funktioniert hat, ist desinformation und Willenbrechen. Also die haben ja auch diese radio-geschichten gemacht mit Marlene Dietrich, als die eben dann die Deutschen gesagt hat, jetzt wehrt euch nicht mehr, stellt euch und so. Das hat funktioniert. Aber diese operativen Geschichten mit hinter den feindlichen Linien irgendwelche Sabotageakte zu machen und ja, das war alles ein Griffins Klo.
Ja, war bei den Briten auch nicht sehr viel anders. Die haben ja von den Leuten, die sie nach Frankreich geschickt haben, haben sie auch nur sehr wenige wiedergesehen. Also interessant war ja, es gibt seit Neuerem ein Buch über die desinformationsoperationen am Zweiten Weltkrieg. The Deceivers von, ich glaube, Bruce Holdt, Historiker und ein bisschen unhandlicher Schinken, aber der beschreibt halt sehr ausführlich, wie die strukturell liefen und was sie sich dafür gestalten angehört haben. Die haben dann halt auch diese künstlich generierten Armeen, also wo sie halt nur einen Generalstab und ein paar Aufblaspanzer hatten, mit denen sie dann die landoperation abgetarnt haben und systematisch also strategische desinformationen und strategische Irrführungen betrieben haben und wie sie das entwickelt hatten. Die Linkliste ist ein sehr interessantes Buch für jemand, der sich da für die Details interessiert. Und da sind unter anderem auch eine Menge so Bühnenbauer, Zauberer, Schauspieler und so, die dann halt also die wesentlichen Leute dabei waren, weil die die Kreativität hatten, dann solche Sachen zu machen.
Das ist ja auch, ich meine, das leute ich auch ein. Es ist ja auch an anderer Stelle, also wenn man sich ansieht, was die Nazis auch so an Waffenforschung für teilweise wirklich bizarre Projekte losgetreten haben, wenn man verzweifelt genug ist, dann geht das plötzlich.
Bisschen zu solchen Sachen, dass sie dann Flugzeuge haben abstürzen lassen, wo denn die Leute früher vorher abgesprungen sind, wo sie irgendwelchen Kram eingebaut haben, also so Fake-Elektronik-Hardware, nur um Analyst-Kapazitäten auf der anderen Seite zu verschwenden, weil die versucht haben, rauszukriegen, was ist denn jetzt wieder für ein krasser neuer Radar-Detektor, den sie da haben?
Also zu dem Thema passt vielleicht Jasper Maskelin. Das war der War-Magician. Maskelin entstammte einer Dynastie der Maskelins. Das war also eine Zauberer-Dynastie, die übrigens als erste Menschen haben schweben lassen. Und das sehr überzeugend Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts. Und Maskelin wurde dann, wie du eben gesagt hast, im Zweiten Weltkrieg rekrutiert und kam zu einer Einheit, um eben täuschungsoperationen einzustielen. Und der wurde auch eingesetzt gegen Rommel, der ja auch so ein Fuchs war. Er wurde ja der Wüstenfuchs genannt, weil der eben diese Geschichten gemacht hat. Kennst du das mit den Panzern? Der hatte da in Tripolis, hatte er also eine Militärparade gemacht. Und hat Rommel Panzer fahren lassen. Und dann, wenn die gefahren waren, sind die im Kreis.
Genau, genau.
Da kam es immer wieder.
Die Russen haben das später auch gemacht mit Flugzeugen. Die haben sogar ihre Nummern zwischendurch geändert, damit die Amerikaner klatschen können.
Der ist ein beliebter Trick bei Militärparaden.
Und bei Marskelin war das nämlich so, dass er eben auch, genau wie Rommel, eben LKWs als Panzer getan hat und pannte Panzer als LKWs. Das heißt, man wusste aus der Luft nie genau, was ist das jetzt? So eine Art Hütchenspiel XXL, wenn man so will.
Das ist ja immer noch. Also da gab es neulich erst wieder so einen.
Mit den russischen Aufblastpanzern.
Genau, mit den russischen Aufblastpanzern. Und die Briten sind da auch relativ früh stark vertreten gewesen. Also das ist eine alte Kunst sozusagen. Und es macht ja auch Sinn. Auch die Deutschen haben das im Übrigen gemacht im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Es gibt eine Legende, das ist aber sehr ungesichert. Der Hafen von Alexandre, den hätte er dadurch geschützt, indem er eben die Beleuchtung hat ausschalten lassen und in der Büste die Silhouette von dem Hafen durch Licht nachstellen ließ. Das heißt, die positionslichter von Schiffen, die da scheinbar sind. Das heißt, wenn dann nachts Bombenangriffe kamen... Das ist ja schlau. Aber jetzt kommt es. Diese Nummer haben die Deutschen genauso gemacht. Im Penomenum. Unter anderem da. Also es gibt auch bei mir jetzt in Nordrhein-Westfalen, da gibt es auch einen Flughafen, der also komplett getarnt war und einige Kilometer weiter kompletten Fake-Up aufgebaut worden war. Und das hat funktioniert. Die haben also da so einen Torfmoor in Brand gesetzt. Und dem Flughafen ist nichts passiert. Da gibt es noch eine tolle Story. Und zwar, in Süddeutschland gab es einen deutschen Flughafen, der also auch getarnt war für den, damit es auf der... Und damit die Luftaufklärung das nicht sehen konnte, hatten die die Runway grün gestrichen und hatten da sogar eine Kuh drauf gemalt von oben. Nur irgendwann ist dann bei der Luftauswertung aufgefallen, dass die Kuh sich nie bewegt hat.
In Peenemünde haben sie ja den Flughafen zum Teil flutbar gemacht, sodass sie halt einen Teil des Flugfeldes da fluten konnten und das dann auch wieder ablassen konnten, um die Küstensiloette weiter nach innen zu verlegen. Und weil die Bomber natürlich, wenn die von See angeflogen sind, um da die raketenproduktionsstätten zu bombardieren, haben die natürlich mit dem optischen Visier die Küstenlinie angepeilt, weil es ein fester Marker ist und von da aus dann eine Kompassrichtung und dann Sekunden der entsprechenden Geschwindigkeit, die sie hatten, bis zum Abwurf. Und die haben halt die Küstenlinie nach innen verlegt und dadurch haben die zu weit innen gebombt. Und da waren halt die Gefangenenlager. Deswegen sind da auch so viele Gefangene umgekommen, weil die dann halt da gebombt haben und nicht bei den produktionsstätten. Also Teile dieser Infrastruktur sind zum Teil noch vorhanden. Das war dann mal irgendwann Anfang der 90er, als da auf diesem Gelände in Peenemünde die ganzen NVA-LKWs zusammengezogen wurden, aus den norddeutschen Stützpunkten, um die zu verkloppen. Da sind wir halt mal hingefahren, um uns wieder anzugucken und sind dann da auch mal durch den Zaun, also naja, es war jedenfalls nicht ganz offiziell der Besuch.
Militärisch Potting.
Und dann haben uns dann da die Wachschützer eingesammelt. Wir dachten so, jetzt sind die halt stinkig, weil wir hier rumgelaufen sind, aber die waren nur schwerstens besorgt um uns, weil wir uns halt da durchs Gras geschlagen hatten.
Ach, weil es da noch Minen gibt oder was?
Ich wusste es nie. Da gibt es halt so acht Meter tiefe Ablaufschächte. Die haben uns mal einen davon gezeigt.
Ach, wegen dem Fluten?
Ja, das sind halt die Drainageschächte dafür. Und wenn du da rinfällst, da find ich nie jemand. Da waren die einfach immer so besorgt, als sie uns dann aus dem Graskratzen nach vorne zur Tür fuhren.
Wie war dieser Begriff noch mal mit den erlebnisorientierten Jugendlichen?
Ja, genau, ich war auch ein erlebnisorientierter Jugendlicher insofern. Diese Geschichten der Pädemünder gibt es noch einige von mit den Häfen, sodass sie versucht haben, einfach konstruktiv Tarnung mit einzubauen.
Das ist ja übrigens auch der Grund, warum die Kirchen so häufig das Bomben überlegt haben, weil das hat man als...
Die waren die Aimpoints, ja.
Genau, danach haben sich die Bomber ausgerichtet, um die eigentlichen Ziele zu treffen. Deswegen haben sie die nicht weggemacht. Das hat nichts mit der Liebe Gott schützt, uns zu tun, sondern das ist ganz technisch erklärbar.
Weißt du, was die Briten in Hamburg als erstes bombardiert hatten? Das Finanzamt.
Weil es brannte so schön?
Nee, aber um die Wirtschaft klar zu machen. Kriegswirtschaft wird dadurch zervortiert.
Die Steuern können die nicht mehr einnehmen.
Aber es ist ja durchaus begrüßenswert.
Mit Sicherheit haben sie sich beliebt gemacht in Hamburg. Ich hätte noch ein anderes Ziel in Hamburg, aber das werden wir jetzt nicht. Komm, ich nehm mich heute gerade her.
Das ist aber lieber außen vor. Das tut doch bloß wieder Ärger, du musst doch häufiger nach Hamburg. Zum Stichwort strategische Ziele vernichten. Es gibt ja diese Geschichte, dass in Amsterdam wurde irgendwann das Bevölkerungsregister vom Widerstand abgebrannt, nachdem die Nazis da einmarschiert sind, um die Juden zu retten, die natürlich da in diesem Register drin standen. Interessant ist, dass dabei ein großer Teil des Registers tatsächlich auch überlebt, aber so etliche 10.000 Leute konnten sich deswegen verstecken, weil sie dann plötzlich unregistriert waren. Das ist ja so eine der Dinge, über die die Holländer immer nicht so gerne reden, ist, dass sie natürlich sehr effizient organisiert sind. Und wie auch immer gerade die Obrigkeit ist, den helfen sie halt. Und der holländische Widerstand da hat dann halt gezielt versucht, eben genau die Juden zu retten, indem sie halt diesen Register abgefackelt haben. Und der Erfolg war halt zumindest, dass etliche tausend Leute dadurch überlebt haben. Also es macht halt schon immer Sinn, die Datenbestände anzugreifen.
Okay, die USS, wie kommt es denn, dass der USS aufgelöst wurde?
Beziehungsweise ungegründet.
Ja, also es gab schlicht und klar... Also erst einmal die Generalität, die war schon immer dagegen. Und man muss dazu wissen, dass es bei den Amerikanern sehr viel Rivalität gibt, die einzelnen Waffengattungen rivalisiert miteinander. Diese Geheimdienste, dass da irgendwie andere Leute operationen machen sollen, das hat denen gestunken. Und es gab schlicht und ergreifend keine Hinweise darauf, dass das USS irgendwas genutzt hat. Es gab genau einen USS-Agenten, der Kriegswesentliches geleistet hat. Das war Allen Dulles persönlich. Allen Dulles war ein Wallstreet-Anwalt, der vorher Diplomat war. Und der ist während des Zweiten Weltkrieges als Agent mit der Nummer 001 übrigens. Kein Witz, den hatte sich 001. Ist er in die Schweiz und hat eben dort versucht, seine Kontakte zur deutschen Wirtschaft zu pflegen. Ja, das wohl auch. Ist ein bisschen umstritten, was er da gemacht hat in Bern. Aber er kannte halt sehr viele deutsche Industrielle. Und es gab ja auch viele Artliche, die mit Hitler sich nicht so identifiziert hatten. Und da war er eben Anlaufstelle für Leute, die den Amerikanern irgendwas bringen wollten. Und da ist mir das große Glück widerfahren, dass Fritz Kolbe zu ihm gegangen ist. Fritz Kolbe war ein Mitarbeiter des Deutschen Auswärtigen Amtes, der eben aus eigener Einsicht beschlossen hat, dieser Krieg muss jetzt beendet werden. Und dann verlieren wir ihn lieber. Und lieber fahre ich mein Land als, dass der Krieg jetzt weitergeht. Hat sich bei verschiedenen Leuten angedient. Bei den Briten haben wir ihn rausgeworfen. Alle möglichen Botschaften wollten in der Schweiz mit ihm nichts zu tun haben. Aber man hat eben gesagt, da ist dieser Amerikaner dort. Allen Dulles hat ihm zugehört, hat die Dokumente gesehen, war begeistert. Und Fritz Kolbe ist nach dem, was die Geschichtsschreiben heute weiß, war er der wichtigste spion des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Und insofern war Allen Dulles ertragreich. Auch weil er durch Zufall als durch Leistung? Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, die haben im Prinzip einen Briefkasten. Genau wie heute WikiLeaks. Man hält einen Briefkasten auf, jemand schmeißt was rein.
Also so einen Briefkasten braucht halt einfach auch eine gewisse Kompetenz. Also muss man schon sagen, dass irgendwie so mit diesem, also dem Know-how, wie man Nachrichten übermittelt und Nachrichten austauscht und eben Briefkasten spielt oder eben dem Versagen dabei sind ja durchaus nicht ganz wenige operationen aufgeflogen oder untergegangen.
Ja, also bei Fritz Kolbe war es so, dass ihn viele für einen deutschen Provokateur hielten.
Das war der Klassiker. Das ist ja immer wieder so.
Die besten Agenten wurden erst mal abgelehnt, weil man sie für falsch hielt. Für Doppelagenten.
Ja, da kommen wir vielleicht noch später zu James J. Angleton und seiner violence of Mirrors.
Zum Beispiel.
Vielleicht sollten wir es ja gleich machen, diese Geschichte mit den Doppelagenten. Es zieht sich ja eigentlich durch die Geheimdienstgeschichte wie ein roter Faden. Also dass jeder Geheimdienst glaubt, dass ein anderer Geheimdienst versucht, irgendwelche Leute unterzuschmuggeln und ihm...
Na, das stimmt ja auch, es ist weit weniger erfolgreich als die, oder?
Dann versuchen sie, die wiederum zu enttarnen und umzudrehen, sodass sie denen wiederum Sachen umdrehen können. Das berühmteste Auffahrer davon ist James J. Engelton, ein CIA-Chef, bzw. ein cia-konterspionage-chef, der ist halt irgendwann durchgeknallt.
Ja, er hatte mit einem...
Die Russen haben ihn so lange getriezt, bis er durchgeknallt, das ist ein bisschen unklar.
Nein, der Leiter der englischen Abwehr, ein gewisser George Blake, war sehr eng mit Engelton befreundet und die haben auch zusammen gesoffen, ohne Ende, also die müssen unglaubliches Zeug vertragen haben.
Das ist wohl bei Geheimdiensten auch üblich, dass er so dem Alkohol zusprechen.
Ja, das ist schon üblich. Das sind ja auch die meisten Todesfälle im Geheimdienst. Die sind ja Leberzirrhose. Jedenfalls, also erstmal, er war mit George Blake gut befreundet und imsofern hat er dann sowieso alle Geheimnisse verraten. Das Problem ist nur, dass halt George Blake nach dem Korea-Krieg dann doch nicht mehr sich so mit der Krone identifizierte, sondern eher mit dem Kommunismus und das heißt also praktisch alle operationen, die da liefen, waren schon verraten, bevor sie überhaupt in näheres Planungsstadium gerieten. Ganz ganz oben haben die Russen oder haben die Soviets ihre Leute da platziert und das hat natürlich den Engelten getrieben und die glaubten halt immer, sie haben einen großen spion im eigenen Laden, in der CIA selbst. Engelten selber war ja eigentlich der spion, weil er im Suff eben ausgepackt hatte und geplaudert hatte. Und dann ging eben in der CIA eine riesige Verschwörungshatz los, die übrigens noch jedem Geheimdienst befallen hat. Also wenn man denkt, man hat einen Maulwurf im eigenen Laden, verdächtigt jeder jeden, da geht eine Hexenjagd los. Und das hat also einige der Dienste wirklich förmlich gelähmt. Wäre es also besser gewesen, einfach zu sagen, ja gut, dann haben wir halt einen Maulwurf und wir machen jetzt unseren Job weiter.
Na ja gut, also es kommt drauf an, aus welcher Perspektive du darauf guckst. Ich als mich verfolgt fühlender Bürger finde das schon in Ordnung, wenn sich die Geheimnisse gegenseitig leben, weil sie sich alle für unterwandert halten.
Black gehört ja zu dieser Gruppe, die die Sowjetzis auch sehr früh angeheuert haben, also die ja doch schon perspektivisch sehr lange dabei war. Von dieser Geschichte haben sich die Briten auch nie so richtig wieder erholt, so bis in neuere Zeiten.
Das ist egal, wie das Chef in Doppelagent ist, ist schon... Wem will sie das toppen?
Da geht nicht mehr so viel.
Wobei das nicht so selten ist, also hier die BND, man hat ja auch in ein oder anderen wirklich peinlichen Fall gehabt.
Ja, der Verfassungsschutz hat noch peinliche Fälle gehabt.
Aber gut. Also eine Sache wollte ich noch...
Der sowieso, aber ganz am Anfang der Typ, der irgendwann im Osten war, ist mir der Name entfallen. Aber gut, finden wir gleich.
Was ich im Vorbeigehen noch sagen wollte, ist Dulles war nur einer von zwei Brüdern und sein anderer Bruder war Secretary of State, ist also der Außenminister und war Teil der Eisenhower-Regierung. Und die haben zusammen, hast du mir vorhin erzählt, auch den Eisenhower finanziert.
Ja, fangen wir früher an. Die Dulles-Brüder waren die beiden Köpfe der Anwaltsfirma Sullivan & Cromwell. Das ist eine Wall-Street-Anwaltskanzlei, die spezialisiert ist auf Außenwirtschaft. Die waren also schon immer ein bisschen tricky gewesen, zum Beispiel mit dem Suisse-Kanal und diese ganzen Geschichten. Die haben also auch öfters mal eben pr-operationen lassiert oder eben irgendwelche Handlanger hingeschickt, die schmutzige Arbeit gemacht haben. Diese Firma Sullivan & Cromwell hatte fast die halbe Wall-Street repräsentiert, was Auslandsgeschäft betraf, auch in Südamerika und überall. Die beiden Dulles-Brüder waren das Herz der republikanischen Partei. Die haben dann eben den Eisenhower auch finanziert. Eisenhower selber war ja parteilos gewesen. Er war von beiden Parteien umworben worden, weil er der große Kriegsgeldjähr war. Er hat sich dann aber für die Republikaner entschieden. Was die Außenpolitik betrifft, das hat alles der John Foster Dulles gemacht, Außenminister. Den Geheimdienst hat dann erst einmal der Dulles mehr so hinten herum aufgebaut. Formell hatten ihn andere Leute geleitet. Er wollte eigentlich nur so Lobbygruppen leiten, aber später hat er sich dann doch da rein gewanzt und leitete dann eine Abteilung eben für schmutzige operationen. Man nannte es Department of Dirty Tricks. Also man nennt es offiziell anders. Dann später hatte dann den Geheimdienst auch so gegen Ende der 50er übernommen und groß gemacht und aufgebaut. Und Dulles hat also der CIA sein Stempel aufgedrückt. Und der Herr Dulles hatte 54 oder ein kleines Problem. 54 hatte er erst mal Erfolge. Die hatten ja diese Guatemala-Geschichten gemacht. In Guatemala hatten sie eine revolution inszeniert mit PR-Leuten. Sie haben also nur ein paar Böhmchen geschmissen. Und sie haben mit Komikern, mit Stimmi-Imitatoren, haben sie also radionachrichten gefälscht und also vorgemacht, dass sich jetzt die Bevölkerung gegen den Arbenz, den damaligen Staatschef, auflehnt, der so eher so fortschrittlich war. Aber das war natürlich dann gleich kommunistisch und schlimm.
Das klingt ein bisschen an War of the Worlds, oder?
War of the Worlds?
Na, es gab diesen legendären radiobroadcast von...
Ach so, ja, klickt ihr weg.
Genau.
Ja, logisch. Ja, klar.
Na, das muss man jetzt auch kurz zu Ende erzählen. Das war...
Orson Welles? Orson Welles hat auch übrigens einen Hobby-Zauberer.
Das war ein radio...
Da freut sich langsam ein Muster, oder?
Ja, passt auf die Zauberer auf. Na, das war so eine radiosendung. Und damals hat radio noch die Einschaltquote gehabt. Die ist Halloween ausgestrahlt worden, auch das noch, und zwar 1938. Und lief bei CBS. Die haben damals also richtig hohe Einschaltquoten sowieso schon gehabt, aber in dem Fall sowieso, und in der radiosendung ging es darum, zu sagen, die UFOs sind gelandet und übernehmen gerade unser Land. Und das hat zu Panik, zu Massenpanik geführt in der amerikanischen Bevölkerung damals, weil die Leute das alle geglaubt haben. Und wenn man das heute anhört, klingt das gar nicht so furchtbar, weil wir alle schon Horrorfilme verwöhnt sind. Aber damals, die Leute haben das also reihenweise geglaubt und haben sich in ihre Bunker zurückgezogen.
Aus Land gefahren.
Das funktioniert, ja, das funktioniert. Na klar, deswegen haben die das auch in Guatemala gemacht und da hat das auch funktioniert.
Ja, Medien und Geheimdienst ist sowieso eine Beziehung, die auf der Hand liegt. Im Iran, der putschte, hatte die CIA auch mitgewirkt. Und das ist dem da alles geglückt. Als der Koreakrieg losging, da hatten die Amerikaner keinen einzigen Agenten dort. Das heißt, sie hatten überall Agenten, wo sie unnütz waren, aber da, wo sie gebraucht hätten, hatten sie keinen. Die CIA hatte in den, sie war 1947 gegründet worden und sie hat also permanent nur Misserfolge eingefahren. Im Osten war die CIA absolut blind, sie wussten nichts über den Osten.
Das war in Russland auch so. Also ich hab, das ist ein Buch, das werde ich hier auch listen, Legacy of Ashes heißt das, das ist ein, wie sagt das, so heißt das auf Deutsch?
Der Titel ist irre, finde ich, mag ich gar nicht nennen. CIA, die ganze Wahrheit.
Also liest lieber die englisch-station.
Ja, nee, es ist aber nicht die ganze Wahrheit, ja.
Nein, ist natürlich nicht die ganze Wahrheit. Wenn ein Amerikaner ein Buch über amerikanische Geheimnisse schreibt, dann kann man sich überlegen. Aber es ist, es ist viel genug, um interessante Geschichten drin zu haben. Und eine ist eben, und eine ist eben, dass die, die Amis jahrelang einfach überhaupt Null Agenten in der sowjetunion hatten. Also Null. Wirklich Null. Und dann ist irgendwann haben sie einen gehabt, aber das war auch keiner, den sie akquiriert haben, sondern das ist jemand, der bei ihnen reingelaufen ist so, hallo, ich würde gern spionieren bei euch, wie ist denn das Prozedere? Und dann haben sie wochenlang, haben sie den da hingehalten.
Den Nosenko meinst du jetzt?
Weil sie nicht wussten, ich hab hier den Namen hier nicht notiert.
Den, den sie in die Kiste gesteckt hatten da.
Aber sie haben also, haben Wochen gebraucht, bis sie sich selbst davon überzeugt haben oder beziehungsweise bis sie halt entschieden haben, dass sie dem glauben wollen.
Ja, also du meinst wahrscheinlich den Nosenko, das war ein Überläufer und den haben sie erst, die haben sie ja nicht Wochen, sondern den haben sie meines Wissens jahrelang irgendwie in solche Anstalten gesteckt und mit Drogen und so vollgepumpt und gefoltert ohne Ende, um eben zu wissen, ist er jetzt echt oder nicht. Das war dieser Jesus.
Vier Monate lang lese ich hier gerade. Das war eine Kenntnis.
Okay, dann nehme ich die Jahre zurück. Wie er mit dir auszahlen, haben wir sie dann nicht.
Nein, aber das kann sein, dass es ein anderer war. Also das gibt, das ist durchaus, das gibt es durchaus häufiger. Das, wenn jemand kommt, ich meine, das ist ja auch klar. Nehmen wir an, du bist im Heimdienst und da kommt jemand und sagt Hallo, ich bin Russe. Und ich will auspacken, dass du den erst mal für desinformationen hälst, natürlich. Also das liegt auch irgendwie nahe. Nur da kann man halt am Ende auch nicht viel tun. Wenn man vorher null Agenten hat, dann gibt es auch wirkliche Möglichkeit zu prüfen. Normalerweise würde man denen halt irgendwie Sachen fragen und die dann unabhängig verifizieren. Aber wenn du halt genau null Möglichkeiten hast zur verifikation, dann ist es halt schwierig. Aber ich würde sagen, das ist der Zustand gewesen in der sowjetunion und das wäre nun ihr Hauptfeind. Und wenn sie da schon null hatten, dann ist es nicht verwunderlich, dass sie in Korea, wo sie sich noch schwieriger in die Bevölkerung reinschmuggeln können, schon weil sie anders aussehen.
Ja, nur überleg mal, da ist es plötzlich nach dem langen Marsch, eine Armee, wie viele Leute waren das, die aufgetauscht sind?
Was, die Chinesen? Eine million Chinesen?
Ja, plötzlich waren da eine million Freibachter. Und die Amis haben nichts gemerkt.
Ja, aber...
Das ist der Hammer und das heißt also, die CIA hatte ihren Auftrag, informationen zu sammeln, die irgendwie brauchbar sind, einfach permanent nicht erfüllt. Und deshalb waren die unter...
Eigentlich waren wir noch bei der USS, die hat ja schon alles verkappt. Wieso ist denn die USS aufgelöst worden?
Ja gut, weil die USS kein...
Verkackt haben.
Ja, genau.
Was war denn der konkrete Anlass? Da gab es doch einen konkreten...
Ja, der Krieg war um.
Eisenhower hat doch irgendwie Druck gekriegt. War das nicht so?
Ja, ich mein, es war halt eine Gurkentruppe und... Nachdem dann die USS einfach per Dekret eben dann aufgelöst wurde, Krieg rum und hat nichts gebracht und so, da erhob sich halt ein Riesengeschrei unter den Veteranen und die haben also eine Riesen-PR-Geschichte gemacht. Die haben ihre Heldentaten besungen in Comics und ich glaube, Lieder haben sie auch noch geschrieben. Und es gibt auch einen Film, der heißt USS und der ist von Richard Maibaum. Das ist der Typ, der dann später auch James Bond-Filme gemacht hat. Also es schließt wieder die Welt von fiktion und Geheimdienst.
Also ihr habt einen PR gemacht, wir brauchen doch einen Geheimdienst und deswegen ist die CAA gegründet worden.
Ja, genau so.
Und ursprünglich hieß es doch, na gut, aber nur wenn die ganzen Pfeifen von der USS draußen bleiben.
Genau. Aber das hat sie dann doch nicht. Sie haben die Hand versprochen und gesagt, nur ein paar Leute und innerhalb kürzester Zeit hat sich die CAA vervielfacht.
Das waren ja auch nur ein paar Leute, die haben halt ihre Freunde mitgebracht.
Und die waren halt auch alle aus dem USS. Da haben sie halt noch diesen Kult, diese Ein-Mann-Schlachtschiffe da, dass sie das mit Fallschirm da einsegeln müssen. Also immer wenn du CAA Mitglied werden willst, musst du Fallschirmabstummen machen, auch ein Ende. Hab ich schon erzählt vorhin, ne? Ja.
Ansonsten kannst du zur NSA gehen, die wollen keinen Fallschirm, sobald ich weiß.
Weicheier.
Die wollen, glaube ich, nur adäquaten Umgang mit der Axt, falls mal wieder so ein Flugzeug in China zur Landung gezwungen wird.
Na ja, das ist ja...
Die Geschichte bezieht sich darauf, dass die Chinesen haben ja ein Flugzeug der Amerikaner, also ein spionageflugzeug. Da flog einer von ihren Jägern so ungefähr dagegen, wo es ein bisschen unklar ist obwärts, ob das ein Pilotenflieger der Chinesen oder der Amis war. Hier war jeweils die eine Sache.
Vielleicht war Amo alle und dann hat er gesagt, den holen wir jetzt runter.
Nee, nee, das war wohl eher so zu nah dran. Wir gucken mal.
Ich meine, sag mal, wie peinlich ist das denn, wenn du mit einem spionageflugzeug so nah ranfliegst, dass du kollidierst?
Nee, die Jäger sind ja dazu da, um das spionageflugzeug abzudrängen und zu intimidieren.
Na, an sich ist doch die Idee, dass die gar nicht merken, dass du dein spionageflugzeug hast, oder?
Nee, elektronische Aufklärung fliegst du genau an der Grenzlinie lang, damit du maximale Reichweite ins Land rein hast.
Na eben.
Wobei man sehr oft genug im Kalten Krieg einfach drüber geflogen ist.
Und die Russen halt auch mal solche Sachen gemacht haben, wie dass sie die Funkbaken versetzt haben, also wenn sie wussten, dass die...
Damit die ins Territorium versehentlich eingehen.
Und dann haben sie die halt eisenhart abgeschossen, da sind nicht ganz wenige da aufgekommen.
Krass.
Also im NSA Museum gibt es ja eine große Tafel von ihren Opfern.
Mit den Sternen da, ne?
Genau. Und etliche davon sind halt auf solchen missionen umgekommen, wo die Russen dann halt eisenhart, die runtergeholt haben.
Und deswegen brauchten die Amis GPS.
Naja, die brauchten sie für die Marschleukörper. Aber lass mich die Geschichte mit dem chinesischen Ding zu erzählen. Da war es halt so, dass ein chinesischer Jäger mit der Flügelspitze ein Triebwerk berührt. Und es wurde schon ziemlich versucht, die einfach abzudrängen und zu belästigen, dass sie halt irgendwie keinen Bock mehr haben. Und dann musste das Ding halt in Not landen, in China.
Und die Crew hat es aber überlebt und ist irgendwie noch nach BR-Ausschlachtung rausgeflogen worden.
Die sind halt da gelandet. Nach zwei Wochen oder zehn Tagen haben sie die auch rausgelassen. Das Flugzeug haben sie halt da behalten.
Das haben sie auch irgendwann übergeben, aber so in Tüten oder so habe ich gelesen. Nachdem wirklich klar war, dass sie wirklich jedes winzige Detail irgendwie etwas ingeniert haben.
Was würdest du tun, wenn dir so ein Flugzeug mit voll aktueller NSA-Technologie frei ausgeruht wird?
Gut, aber seit dem Vorfall haben sie ja selbstzerstörungs Sachen immer dabei gehabt.
Das haben sie ja den Powers auch mitgegeben, es hat nichts geholfen.
Neben den Powers haben sie eigentlich weniger Selbstzerstörung.
Na so eine Giftspritze, damit er bloß nicht ausfallen kann.
Er sollte sich selber zerstören.
Ja, aber das war ja auch der Leak am Ende. Die Technologie hat ihn ja nichts genutzt von der U2. Die haben ja den Powers, der hat ja ausgepackt.
Die Technologie der U2 hat sich schon eine ganze Menge gebracht. Also die konnten daraus natürlich rekonstruieren, mit welcher Auflösung die Amis aufnehmen konnten.
Na, war denn da genug übrig?
Na, du kannst aus dem russischen Seitenbericht zu vernehmen, haben die sogar belichtet das Fotomaterial noch gefunden, was sie entwickeln konnten und daraus konnten sie natürlich sehen, was die Amis sehen können mit den Überflügen. Und wenn du so Flugzeuge nicht händekriegst, kannst du allehand daraus rekonstruieren, allein aus den Teilen, die da überbleiben. Und bei den bei den Chinesen war es ja so, dass die festgestellt haben, dass die NSA-Besatzungen in diesem Flugzeug, zum Teil NSA, zum Teil Militär, auch so ein interessanter Unterschied. Der NSA ist da sehr viel militär näher als die CIA. Die kriegen halt auch häufiger Personal ausgeborgt, beziehungsweise die haben jetzt hier auch Dienst gerade. Und die mussten dann halt irgendwie ihre Daten, also ihre Platten vernichten so und hatten halt aber nur so relativ wenig adäquates Werkzeug dabei. Und zudem wackelte dieses Flugzeug wohl ganz fürchterlich, weil das eine Triebwerk ab war und die Steuerung nicht mehr so ganz funktionierte und es auch ein bisschen unklar war, ob sie es mit dem Landen noch hinbekommen, was dann vielleicht deine prioritäten auch so ein bisschen versetzt, wenn es jetzt darum geht, ob du jetzt lieber hoffst, dass du überlebst oder noch irgendwie deine Festplattenzeit träum hast. Jedenfalls ist wohl der offizielle Bericht, wenn man den Internet-Gerüchten glaubt, darf es wer gerne tun, dass ihnen keine sensitive Technologie abhängen gekommen ist, ist wohl einigermaßen Bullshit und da ist wohl doch jede Menge weggekommen.
Aber jetzt haben wir den Gerät.
Ich meine, die Chinesen sind ja auch traditionell guter, Sachen nachzubauen, nachdem wir sie gesehen haben.
Reversen können die wohl, ja.
Wobei, zur Endrettung der Chinesen, also die Chinesen sind ja die erste Macht, die aufgrund von Wirtschaftsspielnage ihre position verlor. Und zwar die Seitenraupe, das war ja das Geheimnis dessen. Die Seitenraupe wurde und Maulbeerblätter, die man eben dafür braucht, die wurden von einem als Mönch getarnten Agenten rausgeschmuggelt und zwar in einem Wanderstab, den man irgendwie aufschrauben konnte. So ist jedenfalls die offizielle Geschichte. Das heißt, die Chinesen sind wirklich das erste Opfer von wirtschaftsspionage. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwann ein Spieß rumgedreht.
Das ist fair.
Wir haben gesagt, das funktioniert, das machen wir auch.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es denn damit das erste Opfer war, zumindest ein sehr frühes, aber so Herstellungstechnologien für alle möglichen Sachen, also angefangen von Schmiedereisen und solche Sachen, die wurden zumindest den Legenden auch schon sehr früh wegspioniert.
In dem Fall hatten halt die wirklich ein Monopol, und da haben die ordentlich dann verdient. Also das hat schon richtig ins Kontor geschlagen. Also die kann man schon mal pumpen.
Das ist auch ein interessanter Punkt, wirtschaftsspinage ist ja auch immer noch ein sehr wesentlicher Aufgabenbestand für der Geheimdienste. Also eigentlich für aller nation dafür zu sorgen, dass die Unternehmen aus dem eigenen Land bevorteilt werden, dass informationen darüber fließen, wie viel die andere Seite bei einer Ausschreibung geboten hat.
Es gab doch mal diese Geschichte, dass in Frankreich alle Hotels angeblich verwanzt sein sollen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da alle Hotels verwanzt sind.
Aber zumindest die teuren Hotels, in denen man absteigen wollte.
Also es gibt diese verwirkte Geschichte, dass die First Class in der Air France eine Zeit lang verwanzt war. Das ging nochmal durch die Presse. Also wenn ich den, wie formuliere ich das jetzt am besten, wenn ich glaubhaften Berichten glauben darf, dann ist es tatsächlich so, dass es auch nicht ganz wenige Hotels gibt, die zumindest mit Kameras, wenn nicht sogar auch akustisch überwacht sind.
Kameras?
Oha.
Na ja, es ist am interessantesten nicht wahr.
Da kommt das Kompromat raus.
Da kommt das Kompromat raus und dann ist es...
Oh, wer ist denn diese?
Genau, kennen Sie diese junge Dame? Da fällt mir diese hübsche Anekdote ein. Die Stasi hat es natürlich auch mal gerne gemacht, zu versuchen...
Wie hieß denn dieses Hotel noch mal an der...
Lass mich mal erzählen.
In Leipzig das.
Lass mich mal die Geschichte erzählen. Und zwar die Akte habe ich dann im Rahmen einer BSTU-Forschung, wurde die, glaube ich, ausgegraben. Also einer Stasi-Unterlagen-Forschung. Da haben sie versucht, einen Kaufmann aus dem Westen während der Leipziger Messe mit einer jungen Dame zu erpressen. Sie haben die halt eben ran gespielt und der hat sich mit ihr vergnügt. Und dann haben sie ausführlich Foto- und filmdokumentation angefertigt und haben ihm halt am letzten Tag bevor er nach Hause fuhr sozusagen das Material vorgelegt und ihn gefragt, ob er denn nicht im Angesicht dieses Materials zur Rettung seiner Ehe und so weiter und so fort da etwas für sie tun möchte. Die reaktion des Kaufmanns war halt die einzig richtige. Also von dem hätte ich auch noch gerne zwei Abzüge und von dem auch noch zwei. Und wenn sie mir das Video, also den Film noch für den Zwinger-Club-Abend verpüren könnten, dann wäre ich ihnen auch sehr dankbar. Und das hat dann wohl auch die moralisch gefestigten Stadtsicherheit, die konnten dann wohl auch damit nicht so richtig umgehen. Jedenfalls haben sie in der Nacht Ruhe gelassen. Also wenn euch mal jemand versucht mit solchen Sachen zu erpressen, wisst ihr, was die richtige Antwort ist.
Oh, das ist aber schön geworden, da möchte ich gerne ein Kopie haben.
Beim Lummer war das genauso. Dem hatten sie also sogar eine DDR-Agentin untergejubelt. Der Lummer hatte eine Affäre im Osten, ist auch ständig rübergefahren, bevor er eben richtig Karriere gemacht hat. Und da hat es dann irgendwann eine Klare Ansprache gegeben, sagt er, ja, ist mir doch egal. Und hat sogar die Affäre fortgesetzt, weil sie sich verstanden haben. Und man hat es also irgendwie nie hochgehen lassen. Der Lummer hat dann auch, als er eben dann wirklich Karriere gemacht hat, und sich dann auch seinen Behörden offenbart hat, hat gesagt, hier gibt es ein kleines Problem und so. Und dann hat er das auch beendet. Und es ist nichts passiert.
Man muss noch sagen, wie der Lummer ist oder gewesen war.
Du bist Berliner. Der war ja irgendwie, was war er genau?
War der nicht Bürgermeisterkandidat oder so was?
Moment, ich hab's jetzt so. Mit einer Susanne Rau war er also liiert. Ganz am Anfang der 80er Jahre bis 1981, als es zum Innensenator brachte.
Stimmt, Innensenator.
Ist auch so ein Typ übrigens, der wie für Geheimdienste geschaffen ist, weil der auch so ein bisschen chillend ist. Und auch ein starker Mann, einen auf rechts außen, aber dann doch mit einer ostdeutschen Staseagent in ein Verhältnis. Also ist schon sehr selbstverständlich.
Vielleicht ist das auch so ein Männlichkeitsbeweis. Könnte auch sein. Naja.
So ich meinte aber eigentlich ein anderes Hotel. Da gab es nämlich noch dieses Hotel Neptune.
Ne, genau, Neptune. Ne, Rostock.
Aber da ist mir davon Kameras nichts bekannt.
Da gab es sogar mal eine schöne investigative Journalismus-Sache in der ARD.
Da gab es eine schöne dokumentation zu, nachdem sie die Stasi-Unterlagen zu diesem Ding da ausgewertet haben. Da gab es auch einiges an Kameraüberwachungen und so weiter.
Und sie haben auch, glaube ich, einen der Techies gefunden, die da installiert hatten. Und haben denen dann gefragt, wie man die aufjahre hier das Kabel hat. Es war schon relativ klar, was da geschehen ist.
Kennst du die Geschichte mit Zucano? Also, in Indonesien war der Mitte der 60er der Staatschef. Und die Amerikaner haben ihn irgendwie zum Kommunisten erklärt, denn jeder, der nicht mit ihnen war, war Kommunist. Und dann wollten sie ihn also blamieren, indem sie einen Doppelgänger gefunden haben, der wie der Zucano aussah. Und da haben sie ihn dann beim Liebesspiel mit Prostituierten gefilmt. Und haben diesen Film dann irgendwie in Indonesien lanciert. Die Amerikaner als Puritaner dachten, das ist jetzt irgendwie für den Mann ein Problem.
Und da hattest du den Wahlkampf benutzt, weil er so männlich ist?
Ja, im Gegenteil. Der Mann war ein Sexprotz. Und es war offen bekannt, dass er seine Wochenenden in den Vergnügungsvierteln verbrachte. Und das hat ihm überhaupt nicht geschadet.
Die Russen haben doch sowas auch gebracht vor ein paar Jahren. Haben sie irgendwie einen oppositionspolitiker, haben sie so ein Lookalike genommen und dann peinliche Filme gemacht?
Ist umstritten. Also man weiß jetzt nicht, ob es jetzt echt war oder nicht.
Na gut, bei den Russen ist ja diese Sache mit dem Kompromat, also so heißt es ja da, die können das. Durchaus normales Mittel der Politik bis hin zu, dass sie das mit oppositionspolitikern machen, denen sie halt etwas zu jünger Mädchen unterschieben und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und in Indonesien, auch immer leise, ist es jetzt aber so, dass versucht wird, halt den homosexuellen Beziehungen unterzuschieben, um da Politiker raus zu kegeln. Und das funktioniert dann tatsächlich. Also damit kommt man doch da in den Gegenden etwas schwieriger durch.
Naja, das war bei uns auch, ist noch nicht lange her, dass hier, dass man als Schwulermann Außenminister werden kann.
Ja gut, die Kiesling-Affäre war ja so ein Tiefpunkt, wo man also, der Kiesling hatte, also General Kiesling war einer der höchsten Generale der Bundeswehr, war aber unbequem, weil er auch Kritik an der amerikanischen Linie geübt hat. Und dann plötzlich hatte man eben jemand gefunden, der dem Kiesling sehr ähnlich sah, auch in der Bundeswehr war, nur etliche Dienstgrade drunter. Und der verkehrte eben in schwulen Lokalen. Und dann hat man eben den geknipst und so eine Schmutz-Affäre gegen den Kiesling in Gang gesetzt. Und das Kiesling, weil ein homosexueller General und so ganz ganz schlimm erpressbar, muss sofort degradiert werden. Allerdings hat sich dann irgendwann die Stimmung gedreht. Und interessanterweise hat er auch die Stasi einen Anteil gehabt. Die haben nämlich diesen Kiesling gemocht, weil er eben nicht auf dieser amerikanischen Linie mitgeschwommen ist und weil er auch jemand war, der aus einfachen Verhältnissen sich hochgedient hatte und Soldatische tun und so. Das hat man irgendwie akzeptiert. Dann hat die Stasi was Irres gemacht. Die hat fiktive Soldatenzeitschriften gedruckt und ausgelegt, wo also dann eben Soldaten sich scheinbar für den Kiesling verwandt haben. Und sie hatten dann auch an eine Geschichte erzählt, die genauso erinnert, die eben genauso gelaufen war. Im zweiten Weltkrieg gab es irgendwie einen deutschen General, der also auch von irgendeinem anderen Nazi-Politiker gemobbt werden sollte. Und der wurde genau mit den gleichen Geschichten, also Vorwurf der Homosexualität und so sollte der gemobbt werden. Was dann auch irgendwann sich als Irrtum herausstellte und zurückgenommen wurde und sehr peinlich war. Und daran haben eben die DDR-Historiker erinnert in Form von westdeutschen Bundeswehrzeitschriften, die es nie gegeben hat. Und wie es aussieht, ist dieser Fake auch nicht aufgefallen.
Das ist doch prima. So, wir wollten eigentlich noch den Teufelsberg erwähnen.
Oh ja, das müssen wir.
Ja, der Teufelsberg in Berlin war ja so der Hauptabhörstützpunkt der Amerikaner. Und auch, also ursprünglich ist er britisch, und die Amerikaner sind da Untermieter.
Weil er geografisch am nächsten an Moskau dran ist von allen Abhörstützpunkten, die die Amis haben.
Das war irgendwie...
Du könntest wohl, bis Moskau ist auch geografisch nicht so, weißt du, die um Berlin herum ist eine relativ unbergige, flache Gegend. Das heißt, da kommt man auch vom Teufelsberg aus, kann man gut gucken. Also Berg ist auch zu viel gesagt, das ist irgendwie 300 Meter oder so.
Der Teufelsberg ist ein Trümmerberg, der aufgeschüttet wurde über irgendeiner Nazi-Akademie, die irgendwie nie so richtig fertig gebaut wurde.
Da gibt es auch tolle Verschwörungstheorien, dass da noch ein Geheimtunnel runtergeht.
Super. Der Teufelsberg ist insofern interessant, als dass es ein aufgegebener NSA-Abhörstützpunkt ist, der mehr oder weniger bei uns direkt vor der Haustür ist. Deswegen waren wir auch ein paar Mal da, nachdem er aufgelassen wurde. Es hat einen großen Turm und wir verlinken auch noch mal die Bilder, wie es da drin aussah, ein bisschen mit der Auswertung dazu. Die haben da verschiedenste Sachen gemacht. Also die haben eine Menge Mikrowellen Richtung Verbindung abgehört, aus der DDR und auch von den Sowjet-Truppen. Die haben sich der Drata und den Funkverkehr der sowjetischen Truppen angeguckt. Und sie haben auch aktiv manipuliert. Also die haben solche Sachen gemacht, dass sie daran geübt haben, die sowjetischen und auch australischen Luftstreitkräfte, wenn es halt losgeht, zu manipulieren. Das heißt, in die falsche Richtung zu schicken. Das heißt also, die Front-Fight-Erkennung an den Funksprüchen zu hacken und dafür zu sorgen, dass sie in dem richtigen Dialekt Replay-Attacken spielen können und die woanders in die Wüste schicken können und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Das lief auch gut, bis die Russen spionen dahingeschickt haben.
Die Russen wussten einiges darüber.
Es war ein Selbstanbieter.
Es war wieder ein Selbstanbieter. Und zwar war es ein türkischer Automechaniker.
Ja, genau, genau.
Interessant ist, was die da noch alles so gemacht haben auf dem Teufelsberg. Da waren halt die Briten und die Amerikaner, die da ihre installationen hatten, die sich so ein bisschen ergänzt haben. Und es ist interessant, wenn man da so rumläuft in den Gängen. Weiß man manchmal nicht so richtig, ob man jetzt noch im britischen oder amerikanischen Teil ist. Aber man erkennt den britischen Teil sehr deutlich daran, dass die drei Klos auf den Etagen haben. Für Männlein, Weiblein und Offiziere.
Lustigerweise gibt es im Päthagon immer vier Klos. Das ist gebaut worden, als es noch Rassentrennung gab. Das ist kein Scheiß, da gibt es Klos für Männlein, Weiblein und das gleiche noch mal für die Schwarzen.
Okay, das ist nicht zu fast. Immerhin genug Klos.
Also erstaunlich, dass sie daran gedacht haben, dass sie Schwarze mal einstellen wollen würden. Ein bisschen progressiv waren sie ja schon, aber das ist schon ein Zeitdruck.
Ich habe vor einigen Jahren durch Vermittlung jemanden kennengelernt, der da mal gearbeitet hat auf dem Teufelsberg. Der hat ein bisschen erzählt, was sie da gemacht haben, was er erzählen konnte, ohne dass er da seine Geheimhaltungs-Dinge verletzt.
Ohne, dass sie dich erschießen müssen.
Das ist ein Teil, was sie verletzt haben. Wir haben auch eine Menge Sachen gefunden da auf dem Teufelsberg, die auch interpretationsbedürftig waren, wo man halt nicht so viel sehen kann.
Wie dieses Special-Schloss, da gab es da so ein Schloss, was alle Lockpicker zum Kopfkranz bewegt hat.
Diese Torsorschlösser zum Beispiel, die da waren, die waren durchaus hochwertig und interessant. Der hat dann mal so ein bisschen erzählt, wie dann so ein Analystenalltag da aussieht und ausgesehen hat. Und das war halt durchaus interessant. Eines der interessanten Details fand ich, dass vor damaligen Zeit auf den Nachrichtenfluss wegen, kann man sich so vorstellen, wie so ein internes E-Mail-Listensystem, wo dann halt aus den Stützpunkten aus aller Welt die Nachrichten reinfließen. Die Analysten, wenn die gerade so ein bisschen Downtime hatten und gerade nicht aktiv in irgendeinen Funkspruch reinhören mussten oder irgendetwas aktiv machen mussten, waren die dazu angehalten, auch die Nachrichten von den anderen Stützpunkten zu lesen, damit sie up to date bleiben, was in der Welt so passiert. Also fand ich durchaus eine interessante information. Ich hätte gedacht, die schotten die da mehr so ab. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass zumindest damals es so war, dass die durchaus wollten, dass die informiert bleiben. Und ja, so ist es, was los ist. Und er erzählte halt von einer Nacht, die ihm besonders im Gedächtnis geblieben ist, wo irgendwie nichts weiter los war. Und plötzlich ist bei den Sowjets und in Ostdeutschland halt komplett der Teufel los. Also da gehen halt irgendwie die Funknetzwerke an, die sie bisher nie gesehen haben. Die Radarfrequenzen werden aktiviert, die bisher nie an waren. Und dann gucken sie halt so nach in ihre Bücher. Und das ist halt so, wie sie sich vorgestellt haben, was passiert, wenn der Krieg losgeht. Das heißt also, wenn die Kriegsvorbereitungen gefahren werden, dann werden natürlich andere Radarfrequenzen, andere Funkfrequenzen benutzt. Dann haben sie gesehen die Befehle, dass die Raketen aus den Garagen gefahren werden, dass die Mordschützen einhalten, also die motorisierte Infanterie mobilisiert ist und so weiter und so fort. Und haben halt eine Flash-Nachricht nach der anderen ins Weiße Haus geschickt.
Und dachten, Scheiße, der Krieg geht los.
Hier geht es jetzt gleich los. Und er meinte halt, da waren einige dabei, die haben da noch gerade so mal eben ihr Testament irgendwie per interner Nachrichten, also internen Nachrichten nach Amiland geschickt, damit es irgendwie rausgeht.
Grüße an meine Familie.
Weil halt ihnen vollkommen klar war, wenn es losgeht, dann landet die erste Nuke auf dem Teufelsberg. Weil den Russen natürlich schon klar war, was die Amis da gespielt haben, nämlich halt zum Beispiel dafür zu sorgen, dass sie mit ihren Luftschreckkräften nicht mehr so viel anfangen können. Und dann dauerte das so 1,5-2 Stunden, bis sich dann langsam rausstellte, wieso die Russen halt so durchgedreht sind. Also warum die da halt völlig dachten, jetzt geht gleich der Krieg los. Und wir haben da mal einen Clip dazu. Das war Ronald Reagan, der beim Mikrofontest einer radioansprache noch einen kleinen Witz machen musste und nicht wusste, dass das Mikrofon schon an war.
Das macht man immer, wenn man professionell mitnimmt. Das haben wir auch hier gemacht, zum Einmessen unserer Anlage. Und wir lesen hier meinen Blog vor. Aber Reagan hat damals gesagt, wir würden jetzt Russland bombardieren, in fünf Minuten gehen die Bomber los. Und das haben die Russen gehört und haben gedacht, Scheiße. Ich meine, ist ja auch richtig, der Reagan war ja auch ein total durchgeknallter Marodeur-Zombie. Hätte ich mir auch Sorgen gemacht, weil dem ist einfach mal zuzutrauen, dass er sagt, oh, das ist mir jetzt genug, ich hab ganz zu alt für den Scheiß. Los mit den Bombern.
Die Russen, also die Sowjets, waren halt zu der Zeit einigermaßen fest überzeugt, also die Generalität und auch die Sinktankster, dass die einzige sinnvolle Strategie für den Westen halt ein Erstschlag ist. Die sind halt schon davon ausgegangen, aus ihren strategischen Spielen heraus, dass der Westen anfangen wird. Und dass es halt so oder so ähnlich halt sein wird. Dementsprechend haben sie ja dann auch diese Systeme, diese Dead-Hand-Systeme, gebaut, die dazu dienen sollten, selbst wenn irgendwie schon alles kaputt ist, dass sie noch ihre Atomwaffen loswerden.
Na also das haben ja beide Seiten gehabt, dass wir noch U-Boote in den Weltmeeren hatten, die im Notfall einen Zweitschlag hätten machen können. Aber es gibt auch diese Dead-Hand-System, gab es auch in Amerika, das war nur mehr menschlich betrieben. Also das war ein Bunker, wo dann Leute saßen und die hätten dann los treten müssen während dieses Dead-Hand-System. Wobei das ist auch nicht ganz klar, da gibt es konkurrierende Ansagen zu. Also es gibt die eine Ansage, dass das System von alleine hätte los treten können. Und die andere Ansage ist, dass sie das nur den Leuten gesagt haben, dass es sozusagen ein Fnord war, um dem Mann, der an der station mit dem roten Knopf sitzt, quasi die Furcht zu nehmen, wenn er jetzt nicht sofort reagiert, dann könnte es zu spät sein. Und das ist ja auch, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, eine sehr schlaue Idee, dass man sowas überhaupt vorsieht.
Aber lustigerweise haben die Sowjets ja vergessen, den Amis zu sagen, dass sie sowas haben, was irgendwie die Idee eines solchen Systems einigermaßen als Absorgung führt.
Die haben sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, das wissen die eh.
Die Amis haben ja durchaus auch durchblicken lassen. Aber die Sowjets haben nie richtig durchblicken lassen, dass es ein automatisiertes System gibt. Also ich meine, bei den Amis ist ja in Wargames spielt die dadurch eine große Rolle, genau diese automatisierte oder semi-automatisierte Auslösung.
Also es gibt noch eine Anekdote, die wir noch erzählen wollen zu diesem toten Handsystem. Denn es ist ja wirklich mal fast so weit gekommen, dass das ist, also mehrfach, aber es gibt halt einen relativ gut dokumentierten Fall, wo das russische System plötzlich, die hatten damals frisch umgestellt von über Horizontradar auf Satelliten, die quasi optischer Hand von reflektionen des Sonnenlichts erkennen wollten, ob eine Rakete losgeschickt wurde oder nicht.
Jetzt wirst du ein bisschen was zu ihm nennen. Ja, also die russischen Satelliten hatten optische Sensoren und die konnten das Feuer der Raketen, das konnten sie also erkennen. Die Russen wussten also, wo die Amerikaner ihre Raketensilos hatten und da wurden lückenlos überwacht, ob es da plötzlich hell wird. Denn das kann man einfach nicht vermeiden.
Die Infrarot-Signatur.
Und die erste Rakete war die erste Stufe.
Nee, nicht Infrarot, das war ja das Problem.
Doch, doch. Mit Infrarot, optisch. Und dann gibt es eine zweite Stufe, die allerdings erst nach 20 Minuten greift, das ist die Radarüberwachung. Und 1983 waren die Russen besonders nervös, denn der Regen hatte mit seiner Rhetorik eben die Zeit wieder zurückgedreht, die Entspannungsphase wurde wieder angespannt, die die Falten hatten das Sagen wieder gehabt. Jetzt muss man wissen, die Russen hatten im Zweiten Weltkrieg mit der operation Barbarossa eben schon einmal einen Überraschungsschlag erlitten. Das wollten sie kein zweites Mal. Außerdem hatten die Russen erfahren von einem Plan, der nannte sich Single Integrated operational Plan, kurz SIOP. Der wurde 1961 vorgestellt von den ultra rechten amerikanischen Generälen, die also von ihrem Präsidenten einen Erststab wollten. Sie wollten also ein Programm aufbauen, dass sie innerhalb von anderthalb Jahren soweit seien, dass sie die sowjetunion und China-Atomar wegbomben könnten. Und zwar präventiv, damit die nicht zu einer Atommacht aufsteigen. Denn damals hatten die Sowjets keine wirklich nennenswerte Kapazität gehabt. Die haben geblöfft, die Amerikaner dachten, Ende der 50er, die Sowjets hätten 500 Atomraketen. Sie hatten tatsächlich, ich glaube fünf waren es, vier oder fünf, was eben aufgrund von spionagesatelliten rausgekommen war.
Na ja, das war auch so ein Versagen der CIA, dass sie dachten, sie hätten 500. Also das ist nicht nur...
Was heißt Versagen? Also das ist ja Taktik, zu sagen Missile Gap, um eben zu sagen, oh, die sind so schlimm.
Nein, im Moment, das war die eine Sache. Aber auf der anderen Seite hat die CIA, wenn die Politiker dann gekommen sind und gesagt haben, wo sind denn die 500 Raketen? Dann hat die CIA gesagt, ja, das können wir nicht ausschließen.
Ja, genau, so ungefähr.
Also das heißt, die CIA hätte schon die Möglichkeit gehabt, zu sagen, das ist alles Bullshit, aber sie haben halt keine Kapazität da gehabt. Wir wussten das nicht besser. Und wollten es auch nicht besser wissen. Naja, also das ist nicht klar. Aber was klar ist, ist, dass sie gesagt haben, naja, wir können es nicht ausschließen. Und damit quasi das befördert haben. Und es gab später Versuche zu sagen, also wir sehen da keine Raketen, aber das kam erst, nachdem der Beweis nicht mehr wegzuläumen war, als sie nämlich ihre Satellitenaufklärung hatten und einfach sahen, dass da keine Raketen sind. Aber das ist überhaupt so ein Zusammenhang, den es häufiger gibt, dass aus Panik irgendwelche nachrichtendienstlichen Sachen los und politischen Sachen losgetreten werden. Und es überhaupt keinen rationalen Grund gibt, warum es jetzt stattgefunden hat.
Ja, gut, gehen wir jetzt zu 1983. Die Russen waren also sehr aufgekratzt. Die KGB-Chefs waren davon überzeugt, dass jetzt wirklich ein amerikanischer Erstschlag bevorsteht. Reagan hatte das SDI-Programm schon raufgefahren. Krieg im Weltall wollten die machen. Sie wollten eben also ein Anti-Atom-Schild aufbauen, um eben nicht verwundbar zu sein. Und das hat man als erstes...
Was ja übrigens lustigerweise ein Teil des ursprünglichen Abrüstungsvertrages zwischen Russland und Amerika war, dass keine Seite so ein System ehemals bauen würde.
Da wurden aber nur bodengestützte Anti-Satellitensysteme besprochen. Und war ja so, dass zugelassen wurde in dem Vertrag, dass es jede Seite zwei lokale Anti-Raketensysteme baut. Und die Amerikaner haben es zwar gebaut und irgendwie deployed für eine Woche oder zwei. Das wurde in dieser interessanten diskussion über die dokumentation, über die Rainbow Bombs, die können wir auch noch mal verlinken, mitbesprochen. Und die Sowjetinien hat tatsächlich zwei solche Systeme gebaut. Eins ist bei Moskau und eins ist in der Nähe. Also schützt einen eines ihrer großen Raketenfelder.
funktioniert's? Also ich bin neun, das ist jemals ein...
Nein, das war die ganze Zeit Bullshit. Und das ist, würde ich auch wieder der CIA anlassen, dass die mit ihren Analysten nicht gesagt haben, hör mal Reagan, das ist science-fiction Bullshit. Das ist Krieg der Sterne, das war einfach damals sehr populär im Kino gerade.
Also die Weltraumgestützten waren zu dem Zeit die Bodengestützten interessanterweise. Da gibt's ne interessante Geschichte, nämlich die, wenn man sich anguckt, wie die Computerentwicklung an der Sowjetinon lief und im Westen, war es so, dass die Sowjetinon hatte immer einen Überschuss an erstklassigen Mathematikern und naja, so Probleme mit Material und Fertigung und solchen Sachen. Also deren Chipfertigung für general purpose, CPUs, also CPUs, die mit normaler von normalen Architektur Software ausführen. Da waren die immer dahinter her. Wo sie aber ganz weit vorne waren, waren special purpose CPUs, also CPUs, die darauf ausgelegt sind, einen einzigen Algorithmus oder ein sehr kleines Subset von Algorithmen direkt an Hardware auszuführen. Und in der sowjetischen Militärtechnik ist es bis praktisch in den 90er Jahren so gewesen, dass die sich dann auch FPGAs gekauft haben, also Chips, auf denen man Transistoren so zusammenschalten kann, wie man sie braucht, dass diese Algorithmen zum Beispiel, um halt eine Bahnüberschneidung von Raketen auszurechnen, also ballistische Interceptors, die in Hardware gebaut haben. Und die waren halt irgendwie Faktor 100 oder mehr schneller als was die Amerikaner hatten. Das heißt also, die konnten halt sehr viel mehr Lösungen, also Bahnlösungen produzieren in der gleichen Zeiteinheit und damit auch sehr viel besser treffen. Weil sie halt einfach aus den Radaraten, die reinkamen, nicht nur alle Sekunde oder alle zwei Sekunden eine Bahnlösung produzieren konnten, die halt den Interceptor auf die reinkommende Rakete lenkt, sondern eben hundertmal pro Sekunde dementsprechend auch sehr viel besser steuern konnten. Und dementsprechend glaube ich schon, dass die zumindest die bodengestützten Anti-ICBM-Systeme der so weit funktioniert hätten.
Also die der Amis haben ja auf ganzer Linie verkackt. Ich meine, die besten Daten gibt es zu diesen patriot-systemen, die sie da gegen Saddam hochgefahren haben, wo es nicht einen Pfeil gegeben hat, wo eine von diesen Abwehrraketen mal irgendwas aufgehalten hat. Da kamen wirklich die blödesten Low-Tech-Skud-Raketen runter, die überhaupt keine Defensive-Measures hatten. Und nicht mal die haben die runtergeholt. Also das ist alles Pipe-Dream gewesen, was die haben gesagt. Totaler Bullshit.
Na mittlerweile behaupten sie, dass es sich zum Laufen bekommt.
Na klar, natürlich.
Sie hatten noch diese Sachen gehabt, wo sie eine Rakete abgeschossen haben, und man muss dann hinterher zugeben, dass sie einen Peilsender in der ziehen Rakete drin hatten.
Ja, ich meine, die Russen verkacken auch gerade ihre neue generation der Atomeilen. Also das ist generell, man sagt ja immer Rocket Sites, das ist halt nicht ganz einfach.
Ja, wobei bei den Russen ja dann tatsächlich wieder ein Materialproblem zu sein fände. Aber was die Luftabwehrtechnologie betrifft, waren die Russen halt schon immer eine ganze Ecke weiter vorne. Insofern, aber wir waren ja gerade bei...
Die Russen wurden also immer nervöser. Der ehemalige KGB-Chef war inzwischen Staatschef geworden. Und man war davon überzeugt, dass es nur noch eine Frage von Wochen ist, wann es denn losgeht. Man hat also allen Agenten im Westen gesagt, wenn irgendwas ungewöhnliches ist, dann meldet es sofort nicht die üblichen konspirativen Wege, sondern ihr müsst sofort anrufen oder Alarm schlagen. Und sei es auch nur, dass vor einer militärischen Einrichtung mehr Autos parken, als es gewöhnlich der Fall ist. Also so nervös waren die. Und dann gab es eben dieses Herbstmanöver. Jedes, ja jeden Herbst gibt es das Manöver der Bundeswehr, der NATO eben, wo eben die sowjetunion traditionell besiegt wird. Oder?
Man spielt das halt.
Und man hat es 1983 eben sehr hoch aufgehängt. Erstmals waren auch Staatschefs wie Margaret Thatcher und Helmut Kohl zu diesen Gewächsständen gekommen, haben sich da sehen lassen. Und die Russen haben also eiskalt daraus geschlossen, dieses Herbstmanöver ist in Wirklichkeit nur eine Tarnung, um die Raketen in Stellen zu bringen und dann jetzt diesen dritten Weltkrieg loszuschlagen.
Das ist auch nicht völlig von der Hand zu weisen, ne? Also ich meine, das macht auch Sinn.
So macht man das.
Übrigens, warum Kohl dabei war, lag an der stationierung der NATO-Raketen in Westdeutschland.
Ach so, da gibt es ein Gewicht sozusagen nochmal.
Ne, also ich meine, von der Zeit her würde das passen, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Das war damals in einer diskussion gewesen. Die waren noch nicht geliefert worden in dem Moment.
Also ich meine, dann macht es aber jedenfalls Sinn, dass ihr demonstrativ zu der NATO-Bugung hingeht.
Und in dieser Zeit eben gab es einen unglaublich riskanten Vorfall. Da hatte ein gewisser Stanislav Petroff Schicht irgendwo bei Moskau in einem Bunker, in dem eben die Daten der Satelliten ausgewertet werden, eben dieser spionagesatelliten, von denen wir vor einer halben Stunde gesprochen haben.
Also um es nochmal kurz zu erklären, das sind Satelliten, die jeweils einen bestimmten Abschnitt der Erde beobachten und da gucken, ob es dort einen besonders hellen Infrarotblitz gibt, wie er halt beim Zünden der jeweils ersten Stufe passiert, sobald er über die Erdoberfläche kommt. Das ist eine Infrarot-Signatur, die auf einem relativ engen Frequenzband passiert und die man relativ gut von solchen Satelliten auserkennen kann. Die Amerikaner haben so ein ähnliches System.
Ja und die neue generation der russischen Satelliten funktionierte bestens. Es war für die Techniker überhaupt nicht vorstellbar, dass es da eine fehlfunktion geben könnte, was anfällig war, waren eben diese Kontrollzentren. Die hatten also zwei Backups gebaut. Es gab wirklich drei baugleiche Anlagen, in denen eben auch die gleichen identischen Leute so besetzt waren. Weil es eben auch oft Probleme gegeben hat mit dem Klima da bei Moskau, wenn auch Elektronik warm wurde und so weiter. Also man brauchte diese Backups. Ich habe mit dem Pettoff mal darüber ein längeres Gespräch gehabt. Und naja, jedenfalls war der also in dem Kontrollzentrum, als plötzlich der Computer anzeigte ein solcher Blitz, ein Start ist da. Der Computer hat selbst geschlossen, Start. Und in dem Moment ging also schon automatisch Alarm los. Man muss dazu wissen, die haben dieses Kontrollzentrum genannt Gefechtswache. Es gab also zwei Sachen, die als Front betrachtet wurden. Das eine waren eben die Grenzsoldaten, die in ständiger Alarmbereitschaft waren und eben diese Gefechtswache. Die haben also zweimal am Tag die Fahne gehisst und eingeholt und Übergabe, Rituale gemacht mit Musik und so weiter. Wirklich um ganz klar zu zeigen, dass hier ist jetzt ernst, hier ist jetzt der Kalte Krieg und hier wird er möglicherweise heiß. Und dann sind nacheinander plötzlich fünf Raketen gestartet. Und da musste eben dieser Petroff entscheiden, was ist jetzt da los. Ruf ich jetzt dieses Telefon an, von dem man nicht wusste, wer eigentlich rangeht.
Wie, der wusste es wirklich nicht?
Nein, das war alles das Need-to-know-Prinzip. Niemand wusste mehr, als er wissen musste. Klar.
Sie haben gesagt, als wenn was ist, nimm dieses Telefon. Und da geht er dann hoffentlich immer drin.
Petroff kannte sich mit der Anlage aus, dann hat sie konstruiert und hat auch dieses Handbuch dazu geschrieben jedenfalls. Und er überlegt sich jetzt, was mach ich? Wenn ich jetzt anrufe, wecke ich einen Hühnerstall. Also es gibt diesen Hühnerstalleffekt, wenn ein Hahn kräht, dann krähen sie alle. Und wenn er jetzt Panik auslöst, dann geht's los. Dann gewinnt der Prozess eine Eigendynamik. Und dann ist er am Schluss derjenige, der die Leute nervös gemacht hat. Und was soll er machen? Fünf Raketen wurden angezeigt, der Computer hat inzwischen geschlossen Angriff. Drei Raketen lässt sich der Computer bieten.
Obwohl nicht im Notfall reichen würden, oder? Wenn sie da drei stationen haben, dann reichen auch drei Raketen.
Ja, also was Petrov nicht wusste, war, dass also schon nach dem dritten Startanzeichen der Oberste Sowjet automatisch geweckt wurde. Also ein ganz geheimnisvoller Anlage war das da. Und dann hat er gesagt, ruhig, alle gehen auf ihre Plätze, alles hört auf meine Befehle und wir warten jetzt erstmal ab. Denn es gab noch die zweite Stufe, nämlich 20, nach 20 Minuten konnte man auf dem Radar verifizieren, dann kamst du in die Reichweite des Überrezentralars. Genau. Und das Problem ist nur, man hatte für den Gegenschlag eine relativ kurze Zeit, nämlich so 3, 4 Stunden oder was. Und es sei denn deine Dead Man's Hand funktioniert oder so. Aber jedenfalls, also die Entscheidungen mussten eher schnell getroffen werden und das hat diesen Moment so riskant gemacht. Und dann nach 20 Minuten warten, die wahrscheinlich doch länger gedauert haben als normale 20 Minuten, der war schweißgewadert und wie auch immer, kam dann von der Auswertung des Radars, wir sehen nichts, da sind keine Raketen. Und das wurde sofort zum Staatsgeheimnis erklärt und die kommission, die geprüft hat, was los war, hat das auch alles erstmal sehr, sehr geheim gehalten. Und das waren tatsächlich eben solche Sonnenspiegelungen an der Atmosphäre, die eben auch leider genau über diesen Silo-Star gewesen war. Es musste unglaublich tragischer Zufall gewesen sein. Und das war ein Effekt, den man so noch nicht kannte. Das heißt also, man hat... Ne, der hatte damals im gleichen Jahr von den 99 Luftballons gesungen. Es war noch nicht mal Luftballons, es war ein Sonnenspiegelung, also gar nichts. Was möglicherweise, wenn der Mann ein bisschen weniger nervös gewesen wäre, wenn der nervös gewesen wäre, unglaubliche Folgen gehabt hätte, denn die Russen hätten sich nun mal auf einen Erstschlag, die hätten sich nicht bieten lassen. Es war Doktrin, es wäre zurückgeschlagen.
Aber hatte... Eigentlich sahen doch aber die Modelle der Russen auch vor, dass die Amerikaner nicht mit fünf Raketen anfangen werden.
Das war damals die Doktrin. Und das war auch der Grund, was sie im Petroff gesagt hat, fünf Raketen, das ist noch nicht der dritte Weltkrieg. Was allerdings nicht gewusst hat, das hat dann später der nato-spion Rainer Rupp gemeldet und auch später in Büchern publik gemacht, tatsächlich war es so, dass die Amerikaner nach Moskau einen Enthauptungsschlag führen wollten. Sie wollten in zwei Angriffswellen im dritten Weltkrieg operieren. Man wollte erst mal gucken, Hauptstadt weg, haben die Russen verstanden, wären die sich noch oder nicht? Wenn sie sich wehren, dann Volltruf. Aber ich meine, im Prinzip, in den dritten Weltkrieg kannst du den nur verlieren. Also gute Frage, ob man sich wehrt oder nicht.
Aber die Ironie ist jedenfalls, wenn Petrov gewusst hätte, dass fünf Raketen durchaus ein realistischer Erstschlag der Hammis sind.
Ich habe ihm das gesagt, da hat er große Augen gemacht. Und da hat er gesagt, wenn er das gewusst hätte, dann hätte er anders entschieden. Das Irre ist, Rainer Rupp hat ja damals als Pazifist, Rainer Rupp ist Kommunist, der die NATO unterwandert hat und später Zugang hatte zu den höchsten NATO-Geheimnissen, Cosmic Top Secret nennt sich das. Und da hat eben Rainer Rupp damals in dieser Rian-Krise, als die Russen so nervös waren, hat er alle möglichen Dokumente den Russen kopiert mit seiner Minus-Kamera und um eben die Russen davon zu überzeugen, hey, das ist nur eine NATO-Übung. Ich bin hier dabei, ich plan die ja selber mit.
Ja, aber das ist das Problem mit Paranoia.
Es wäre ja fast nach hinten losgegangen, wenn die Info zu Petrov gelangt wäre. Dass fünf Faketen durchaus ein realistischer Erstenschlag sein würden.
Dass wir den Kalten Krieg überlebt haben, ist offensichtlich ein großer Zufall.
Nein, das ist vor allem der Inkompetenz der Leute zu verdanken.
Nein, nicht mal unbedingt.
Wenn die Russen gewusst hätten, was...
Die Amerikaner haben ja so ein ähnliches System, also auch so ein Info-System, von dem sie mehrere generationen da oben hatten. Und auch da gab es eine große Menge von Fehlalarm. Und es war halt so, dass die Leute, die das System initial projektiert haben, also die zweite generation, davon, die haben, da gibt es auch ein Sentinels in Space, das heißt, das kann man auch verlinken, das Buch, die haben vorhergesehen, dass es da interessante Effekte geben wird. Und die hatten, also deren Hauptproblem waren z.B. die reflektionen auf Seen. Also wenn die Sonne entsprechend tief steht und auf Seen reflektion sind, dann haben die halt so Maskierungen gemacht, also zu sagen, wenn da in der Ecke was kommt, dann ist die Fehlalarmwahrscheinlichkeit höher, weil da haben wir schon häufiger mal irgendwelche Dinge gesehen. Aber dann hatten sie diese Geschichte mit der pipeline-explosion, wo die Amis den Sowjets Software untergeschmuggelt haben, die dazu geführt haben, dass ihnen da eine Erdgas-Pipeline explodiert ist.
Das hat man auch in dem System gesehen.
Ja, das hat man eben auch in dem System gesehen. Deswegen ist es auch vollkommen logisch, dass sie da jemanden zum NORAD geschickt haben und denen gesagt haben, pass auf, wenn da jetzt...
Das sind keine Raketen, das sind wir.
Wenn da eine Signatur kommt, dann heißt das nicht, dass da gerade ein ganzes Raketenfeld startet, sondern das heißt, dass da alles in Ordnung ist. Bei den Amis war es halt auch so, dass es im Wettbewerb ziemlich häufig große Waldbrände gibt. Also wirklich große Waldbrände, die die auch einfach brennen lassen, weil da ist halt niemand. Das ist dann nicht mehr.
Da kann man sicher sein, dass keiner mehr da ist.
Nein, die haben tatsächlich auch Waldbrände... Auch vorher war das schon geiler.... in einigermaßen unbesiedelten regionen. Die haben sie tagelang brennengelassen bis zum nächsten Fluss. Dann geht es von alleine aus so. Aber so ein großer Waldbrand erzeugt halt durchaus eben eine Signatur, die halt auch auf diesen Infrarot-System zu Federalarm führt. Deswegen haben sie dann irgendwann angefangen, die Signale von diesen Dingern halt nochmal über den Human Operator zu schleifen, der dann irgendwie geguckt hat und so. Und dann erst wenn noch eine Radarsignatur dazu war, dann haben sie was ausgelöst. Wobei Radar natürlich auch nicht zuverlässig ist. Es gibt irgendwie etliche Fälle aus dem Kalten Krieg, wo Vogelschwärme oder sonst irgendwelche bizarren Dinge halt Radarsignaturen ausgelöst haben, wo sie dann auch nicht mehr so recht wussten, ob jetzt diese 99 Luftballons, was du gerade erwähnt hast, der Song, der hat schon einen durchaus sehr ernsten Hintergrund.
Aber kennst du diesen Atomalarm, der von diesen Remote-Viewers kam? Kennst du die Geschichte?
Nee, Remote-Viewing wollten wir sowieso noch weg.
Lass uns mal mit dem Remote-Viewing anfangen.
Wir machen jetzt mal Remote-Viewing.
Ja gut, die haben wirklich mal Atomo...
Gut, der Reinhardt, genau.
Also...
Los ging's mit den Okkultisten im Dritten Reich.
Noch viel früher, ich mein, jeder Herrschende hat seinen Hofmarge in Wahrsage gehabt.
Ja, aber im Dritten Reich, das find ich irgendwie den Hammer. Was das alles für Pfeifen waren, ja, rückblickend. Ein Wunder, dass die so einen Weltkrieg lostreten konnten.
Also der Himmler und der Hess vor allem, die waren also vernarrte Okkultisten und haben also auch versucht, durch eben hell sehr militärische oder eben irgendwelche Geheimnisse zu ergründen. Man hat Horoskope gemacht und so weiter. Und da man wusste zum Beispiel, dass Hessen abergläubig war, hat der britische Geheimdienst sogar mal ein Horoskop von Hitler gefälscht. Nur um die irgendwie irre zu führen.
Die haben kein Glück die nächsten Tage.
Die hatten tatsächlich also eine Hellseereinheit. Da gab es einen Karl Kraft. Der hatte irgendwie das Attentat von Georg Elser auf Hitler vorhergesehen. Zumindest glaubte man das. Und dann war allerdings Kraft nicht mehr so erfolgreich und hat irgendwann sogar gesagt, dass man ein dritten Reich mit der Welt kriegt, die wird wohl nichts mehr.
Rückblickend visionär.
Die Geschichte ist nicht ganz so komisch. Den haben sie nämlich dann daraufhin ins KZ gesteckt. Wenn der Wahrsager nicht das sagt, was man hören will, dann ist er dumm gelaufen.
Das ist ja auch durchaus tradition.
Jedenfalls diese Geschichte, dass man Wahrsager bemüht. Auch der Adenauer ist zu so einer Cassandra gegangen. Ist bekannt. Viele Politiker, auch die Russen hatten ja auch die Juna.
Aber erzähl doch mal die Sache von...
Die Remote US.
Vorher noch, die Nazis. Himmler hielt sich für die rehinkarnation von Heinrich I.
Es gibt also irgendwie so einen Bericht, dass also Himmler, also erstmal Himmler war ziemlich gaga, was auch diese ganzen Hexengeschichten da betrifft. Und der soll sich für den Nachkommen von Heinrich, das Erste gehalten haben. Der hatte also einen Mentoren, das war ein Okultist, der hieß Karl Maria Willigut. Das war ein ariosoph. Das waren eben Leute, die den Okultismus, Spiritismus und alles mögliche zusammengehauen haben. Und dann irgendwie sich eine eigene Ahnenlehre gebastelt haben. Und irgendwie, also der Willigut, so hieß der Mensch, behauptete, er stamm aus einem alten Adelsgeschlecht ab. Und zwar den Willigoten. Und das hat also wirklich der Himmel geglaubt, alles mögliche. Und im Himmel hat sich dann irgendwann mal, heißt es, am tausendsten Todes-Tag oder Geburtstag, ich weiß es gar nicht, von Hannig I in dessen Gruft gelegt und soll also versucht haben, da irgendwie, ja, Ritual.
Die Aure aufzunehmen.
Überhaupt scheinen, also die Nazis der ersten Jahre waren sowieso sehr okkult drauf. Und eben diese Leute, die dann den hohen Etagen da überlebt haben, diesen Römenputsch und diese Geschichten da. Ja, also sehr, sehr, sehr seltsame Geschichten. Also ich hab mal gehört, die durften angeblich, ich hab's nicht überprüft, das war angeblich, bei den Nürnberger Prozessen gar nicht thematisiert werden, dass viele Nazis so okkultismusgläubig waren, weil man dann, weil die, die hätten dann auf Pläm Pläm gemacht.
Nicht schuldfähig, weil unzurechnungsfähig.
Ja, also da kommt ja diese ganze Blut-und-Boden-Ideologie her. Also das ist ja nicht nur eine Metapher, sondern das, das meint nie teilweise Ernst. Man muss dazu wissen, dass es gab halt eine Madame Blabatsky. Die hatte also irgendwie, irgendwie zwischen zwischen den Arianen und, und, und den Inden hatte da irgendwelche genetischen Sachen, eine Verbindung dahergestellt und von irgendeinem Kloster da berichtet, dass es wohl nur in ihrer Fantasie gab. Und die hat eben den Spiritismus sehr hoffähig gemacht und eben auch diese ariasophischen Zirkel gegründet, die dann eben später auch politisch wurden. Und daher kommt auch diese ganze Aria-Lehre, ja, Blutreine. Ach, ist eigentlich viel zu ekelhaft. Komm, reden wir lieber über Geheimdienste.
Nein, aber also aus quasi der, die Fortführung von diesem ganzen Okkultismus-Bullshit ist, dass auch die späteren Geheimdienste glaubten, sie müssen Medien befragen und sie müssten remote viewing es quasi hell sehen.
Also Alan Dulles, als er mit Korea und so weiter keine Erfolge hatte, hat er versucht, da gab es so die Doctrine Anything Goes. Wir müssen jetzt mit allen möglichen Methoden, Tricks und so weiter, wir müssen jetzt Erfolge erzielen. Eine Sache war MK Altra, also diese Geschichte mit den Drogen, Gehirnwäsche und so.
Das ging auch auf populäre Literatur zurück. Erzähl doch mal den Teil.
Es gab einen Roman, The Manchurian Candidate hieß der. Da hat also ein Autor berichtet, wie eben die Koreaner Gehirnwäsche gemacht hätten und Amerikaner so umdrehen, Gehirn waschen, dass sie zu willenlosen drohen werden praktisch und also den Präsidenten erschießen wollen, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe. Schläferagenten würde man heute sagen. Genau. Und dieser Roman, den hat auch der Dulles in die Finger gekriegt und wollte wissen, wenn die Russen können, können die das und wenn sie es können, müssen wir das auch können. Er hat eben ein Programm aufgelegt, das nennt sich MK-Ultra. Und da wurde dann eben von Wissenschaftlern an gewissen Siegmut, Gottlieb jedenfalls, siehst du ja.
Es gab mehrere, der war schon der wichtigste. Der war der Kanadier jetzt, oder?
Mag sein. Und die hatten dann eben Drogenexperimente gemacht. LSD war gerade erfunden worden. Man wollte wissen, ob man eben Leute durch Hypnose und Schocktherapie und so weiter gefügig machen könnte.
Eine Wahrheitsdroge wollte man haben.
Alles mögliche.
Und die haben übelste Experimente gemacht. Ja, an Menschen.
An Kriegsgefangenen haben sie in Deutschland, in Oberursel haben sie Experimente gemacht, die sogar tödlich ausgegangen sein sollen.
Und in Amerika und Kanada war das häufig?
In Amerika haben sie sogar ein Bordell inszeniert. Und eigene GIs wurden von gewissen Damen Drogen in einen Trink gemixt. Und hinter so Zauberspiegeln haben sie gehockt und mitgefilmt und wollten einfach wissen, wie verhalten sich die Soldaten jetzt unter LSD? Was machen sie jetzt? Unglaublich eigentlich.
Also fast alle von diesen MK-Alter-Experimenten sind an Nicht-Freiwilligen durchgeführt worden. Und in Kanada war das ein Typ, der nicht in der Armee war. Das war tatsächlich ein Wissenschaftler. Und der hat in seinem Bunker da, in seiner Klinik hat er an Insassen einer Irrenanstalt experimentiert. Also alles absolut übelst, unethisch. Und es ist ihm auch irgendwann selber aufgefallen, dass das nicht geht. Und haben versucht, die Akten komplett zu vernichten. Aber ein paar haben halt überlebt. Aber insgesamt ist eines der dunkelsten Kapitel der US-Geschichte an der Stelle.
Für mich faszinierend ist, in MK-Alter hat man auch einen Zauberkünstler rekrutiert, John Mulholland. Das war der damalige David Copperfield, wenn man so will. Also war der damals bekannteste Zauberer, der auch Zauberer wissenschaftlich beforcht hat. Und von dem wollte also die CIA lernen, wie Agenten Giftpillen an den Leuten in den Trink geben können, ohne dass sie es merken. Die wollten also wirklich wissen, wie können wir mit den Methoden von Zauberkünstlern im Geheimdienst erfolgreich sein. Der hat also ein ganzes Buch geschrieben, was bizarrerweise eben überlebt hat. Das Buch galt lange als Mythos. Erst letztes Jahr ist ein Exemplar aufgetaucht und wurde dann also gedruckt und ist jetzt sogar zu haben.
Das kann man jetzt kaufen.
Sehr spannendes Buch.
Es empfiehlt sich vor allem wegen der vielen illustrationen, die wirklich sehr witzig sind, wo man halt so sieht. Und dann musst du die Hand so halten. Und hier hast du die Pille.
Ja, also ich meine, das Buch ist mit Sachverstand geschrieben. Also da ist ein Einführungskapitel, wo der Malhallen sich Gedanken macht, was sich Leinen vorstellen, wie Zauberreif funktioniert und was aber wirklich täuschend ist. Und da kann ich jeden Satz unterschreiben. Also der Mann wusste definitiv, wovon er spricht. Nur, ich persönlich halte es, dass die Ergebnisse, die er da hat, ist ein erfahrener Zauberkünstler, der das trainiert hat oder so, aber auch der in einer stresssituation. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es ernsthaft eingesetzt wurde. Es gab so ein paar Zaubertricks, die ich mit meine Castro versucht hab, umzubringen, mit explodierenden Zigarren und solchen Blödsinn. Aber da hat ja alles ein Stück Platz.
Lass uns mal kurz noch bei diesem Buch bleiben, weil was sagst du nicht interessant, ich hab mich mit Zaubertricks nur sehr, sehr am Rande beschäftigt, aber du machst das ja intensiver. Also du meinst, dass die, dass es nicht nur deswegen nicht eingesetzt wurde, weil die das zu komisch fanden, sondern weil es eben genau in so einer stresssituation schwierig ist, solche manipulationen und Tricks sauber durchzuführen?
Also wenn ich jetzt vorhätte, dich zu vergiften, dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich nervös. Ich weiß es nicht. Hoffentlich doch.
Nimm mir lieber mal eine Mateflasche und heize mal dich zu.
Okay. Ja, also...
Ist nicht deine Schweißkahl auf deiner Stube? Also du meinst, also...
Der Druck ist noch ein anderer.
Die Sachen sind extrem gut durchdacht. Ja, also gar keine Frage. So die Gimmicks, die der da konstruiert hat und die Routinen, dass man also sich nach vorne beugt, jedem ein Feuer gibt und dabei mit der linken Hand was fallen lässt, also Zündholz schächtlichen oder sowas. Und das dann genau in den Drink fällt. Das ist alles gekonnt. Aber trotzdem diese, ich mein, Geheimdienst ist Geheimdienst und Zauberkunst ist Zauberkunst. Wenn im Geheimdienst jemand stirbt, dann hat er halt einen Autounfall.
Na gut, das waren ja nicht nur Vergiftungsgeschichten, sondern das war auch durchaus, wie klaut man zum Beispiel was oder wie tauscht man ein Gegenstand aus. So eine Sache war ja ein breites Repertoire von Sachen.
Bühnentaschen-Diebstahl ist jetzt nichts, was ein Amateur ist. Das beherrsch ich nicht. Ich kenne Leute, die es können, aber das ist völlig irreal. Bühnentaschen-Diebstahl kannst du nur mit wirklich guten Ablenkungen und da musst du wirklich verdammt gut sein.
Aber ich meine, auf dem Kuhdarm gibt es eine Menge Leute, die sind echt gut da drin, ne?
Ja, du hörst den Mechanischen Agent.
Also naja, hör doch mal mit deinem Wessi-Beschi rauf, Mann. Scheiß Ostgläuber.
Also ich habe ja da mal eine Weile gearbeitet und da haben wir...
Im Osten gibt es keinen Taschendiebstahl noch.
Nein, lass mich da mal erzählen. Also in der Frühzeit, wo ich da im Westen gearbeitet habe, bei meiner Firma, wo wir noch mit Kameras mit langen Linsen und so experimentiert haben, haben wir halt auch mal so den Taschendieben so ein bisschen zugeguckt bei ihrer Arbeit. Das war durchaus instruktiv so. Also da hat man eine Menge lernen können, wie das funktioniert so, mit irgendwie... Also insbesondere, wenn wir in zwei Teams gearbeitet haben, war das durchaus sehr...
Der eine klopft dir auf die linke Schulter, wir und der rechts was ausklopfen.
Worauf ich hinaus will, ist ja, dass Geheimdienste betreiben, eine Menge Training, also zum Beispiel jemanden verfolgen oder Verfolge abschütteln, ist ja so die Basisgeschichte. Tote Briefgästen bestücken oder entleeren, unaufällig im Straßenalltag, sich irgendwo aufhalten und Sachen beobachten oder ein Objekt zum Beispiel beobachten oder eine Firma beobachten und dabei nicht auffallen. Also diese ganzen Techniken, die lernt man ja da. Also die sind dadurch das Bestandteil des Trainings und die sind ja nun auch nicht einfach. Also es wäre nicht so, dass das dann Fähigkeiten sind, die dir natürlich kommen, sondern im Gegenteil, sind es teilweise Sachen, die deine intuition ja komplett zuwiderlaufen. Also deine intuitiven Verhaltensweisen. Und soweit ich zumindest aus dem Buch verstanden habe und dir ein bisschen über die Quatschhauttricks weiß, ist es ja häufig eben auch so, dass du dich ja eben genau kontraintuitiv bewegst oder also Handlungen durchführst, die halt eben nicht intuitiv sind, um auszunutzen, dass dein Gegenüber annimmt, dass du dich bewegst, wie er annimmt, dass du dich bewegst. Das ist ja so einer der Kerndinge. Meinst du nicht, dass es durchaus möglich wäre, oder dass jemand gemacht hat, dass sie solche Sachen eben in solche Trainings einbauen?
Also in der Auseinandersetzung Mann zu Mann halte ich das für sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ich meine, wenn man sich guckt, wie die kunstvolltäuschungsoperation eingestellt wurde, dann kann man so sagen, ja, das ist wie Zauberkunst, also richtig fachmännisch. Dieser planerischen Ebene, diese informationsgeschichten, das kann ich mir vorstellen, einfach so Mann gegen Mann.
Die haben einen relativ großen Talentpool. Also die haben mir ein bisschen eine Weile angeguckt, wie die Ausbildung funktioniert. Also die normale Street-Smart-Ausbildung. Also diese Geheimdienste wissen zum Beispiel, um Leute zu verfolgen im Straßenbild.
Also es gab den antonio Mendez. Das hat angefangen als Fälscher bei der CIA. Und der hat dann mit Täuschungen wirklich sehr offensive Geschichten gemacht. Da war die Sache in Iran. In den 70ern musste er irgendwie Amerikaner aus der Botschaft rausschmuggeln und musste dann auch aus Landes schmuggeln. Und da hat er Dreharbeiten eines science-fiction-films einer amerikanischen Filmfirma inszeniert. Und hat Latexmasken besorgt und die Leute, die die Amerikaner als Iraner mit diesen Latexmasken maskiert, so wie man das in mission Impossible kennt. Das gab es wirklich. Zumindest steht so in seinen Memoiren. Und er ist ausgezeichnet. Also für diese aktion hat er einen Orden von George Bush senior bekommen. Der mal Geheimnischef war und später dann Präsident. Also das wird ja jetzt nicht zum Spaß diese Auszeichnung gegeben haben. Aber solche Geschichten, die gab es, aber die kann man dann wohl an der Hand abzählen. Und die werden dann die CIA-Leute noch in Jahrzehnten am Lagerfeuer erzählen.
Also du meinst, man kann relativ ausschließen, dass es sich um einen, ja, also...
Also wenn da ein Stein an einer Hand abzählbarer Einzelfälle...
Es gab die Sache mit der Marina Lorenz, die Castro vergiften sollte. Und die hatte in ihrem Cremedöschen Giftpillen geschmuggelt. Und der Malhallen hatte extra einen Kapitel Tricks für Frauen.
Stimmt.
Wo er eben die Kleidung der Frauen ausnutzte.
Und die unterschiedlichen Bewegungsmuster.
Und die damals, die Verhaltensweisen einer Frau gegenüber. Dass man der den Stuhl zurecht gerückt hat, damit die sich setzen konnte und solche Geschichten.
Dass man die ausnutzte.
Ja, genau. Oder dass man eine Frau Feuer gab und so. Das hat er ihm ausgenutzt und recht gekonnt. Also der wusste wirklich, was er tat. Und der war auch ein exzellenter Zauberer. Gar keine Frage.
Ja, das fand ich eines der faszinierenderen Bücher, die ich dieses Jahr gelesen habe. Den war doch eine lektüre. Manchmal ein bisschen, sagt er auch sehr viel über die Gesellschaft damals aus.
Ja, genau.
Dieses Kapitel über Frauen sagt auch eine Menge. Er ist in keiner Weise frauenfeindlich, kann ich gar nicht sagen. Er hat im Gegenteil eine sehr respektvolle Einleitung, wo er sagt, dass Frauen da doch sehr viel mehr Möglichkeiten haben, weil die Männer in der Regel abgelenkt sind und sehr hübsch sind.
Er hat doch eine andere Sache gesagt. Ich kriege es auf die Reihe, dass man nie versuchen sollte, eine Frau zu täuschen. Die würden das immer sofort merken oder so etwas. Ich kriege es jetzt nicht mehr ganz zusammen.
Das klingt wie ein Spruch aus der eigenen Erfahrung.
Er hatte ein Verhältnis mit seiner Sekretärin. Ich glaube, ein Tipp, wie man eine Frau zu täuschen, wie man eine Frau täuschen kann, lassen sie es.
Das ist auch interessant, bei den Sachen, die sie trainieren, ist nicht nur alles rational. Gerade bei solchen Sachen, ob du beobachtest oder nicht, da trainieren sie tatsächlich seinen siebten Sinn an. Menschen merken ja, wenn sie angeguckt werden, auch wenn sie von hinten angeguckt werden. Wenn sie einen gewissen, also irgendeiner, und es muss ja nicht mal sein, dass sie das...
Siegfried Reflex, der Siegfried Stahl von hinten.
Es muss ja nicht mal sein, dass sie das bewusst merken, sondern dass sie unbewusst z.B. reflektionen sehen oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Dass sie einfach ihre Wahrnehmung stärker integrieren, als sie das durch bewusstes Wahrnehmen machen könnten. Und die sieben ja auch eisenhart aus. Es ist halt so, dass die Teams, als observations-teams z.B., sie kriegen zwar eine Grundausbildung, aber die, ob du Talent hast, halt wirklich ein Observateur zu werden, entscheidet sich eben daran, ob du durchhältst. Also ob die diese vielen Zyklen von von observations-trainings, ob sie dich dabei entdecken und die spielen dann halt auch mal gegeneinander. Also die lassen den Newies gegen die Alten antreten.
Mich erinnert das, ich muss wieder an dieses an dieses Jurätsko-Buchdenken-Rall, wo sie erzählt haben, wie die Ost-NVA an dem geheimen Führungsobjekt des BND trainiert hat. Also die haben, nicht nur weil das natürlich im Westen, also das heißt, das ist schon der erste Hammer, dass sie da überhaupt irgendwie hingekommen sind, ohne dass jemand gemerkt hat, sondern sie haben, also der Typ, der vor dem Haus irgendwie Würstchen verkauft hat, war nur alles irgendwelche Außenzubildenden der Ostdienste. Das ist also ein Brüller, diese Geschichte alleine, die Bohnen. Das hat natürlich keine Sau gemerkt. Und der schönste Trick an der Stelle war, wie man dazu kriegt, dass man die Gesichter fotografieren kann. Da haben sie mit dem Haus gegenüber so eine kleine Wohnung gemietet und haben da eine sehr gut aussehende Frau reingestellt, die sich dann strategisch ausgezogen hat, um irgendwie Aerobik zu machen oder so ein Scheiß.
Mit nackten Brust hat sie jeden Tag da irgendwie zum gleichen Zeitpunkt Aerobik gemacht.
Das hat sich halt rumgesprochen und dann sind die alle in dem BND-Gebäude alle zum Fenster gelaufen und haben rübergegafft. Und irgendwie zwei Stockwerke darüber saß der Typ mit seinem Teleobjektiv und hat die ganzen Gesichter programmiert. Also das ist alles Psychologie, natürlich.
Also interessant ist, es gibt da so ein Buch von Fred Burton, das ist einer der Typen, der jetzt gerade bei Strutford arbeitet. Der war früher beim Diplomatic Security Service, DSS der Amerikaner.
Wie viel Geheimdienste haben die eigentlich? Ich hab irgendwie so was gehört wie 17.
Also nach letzter Erzählung.
Heilige Scheiße.
Aber interessant ist, der berichtet unter anderem auch so ein bisschen aus diesen Ausbildungen und so weiter und so fort. Und der hat dann da das ganze Buch, das ist eher so mittelmäßig, aber er hat dann so eine Stelle, für die sich dieses Buch wirklich lohnt. Und zwar über die Kriterien zur Auswahl von konspirativen Wohnungen. Und zwar haben sie dann eine Weile rumgesucht und nach Kriterien gesucht, weil sie konspirative Wohnungen braucht für verschiedenste Zwecke, also um Leute zu vernehmen oder um Leute verschwinden zu lassen oder was auch immer.
Verschwinden zu lassen, aber das ist ja diplomatische Dienst, der nachher sowas nicht hat.
Ja, also bevor sie ihnen halt ins System einspeisen, dass sie ihnen noch mal ein ruhiges Wort mit ihm haben können oder so. Also die Auswahl haben sie dann getroffen. Und zwar gibt es in und um Washington wohl eine Menge Apartment Blocks, die halt so relativ kleine Wohnungen enthalten, wo halt die ganzen Nobbiisten und Politikern so halt ihre Geliebten unterbringen.
Ach, da guckt eh keiner hin. Ja und das ist normal, wenn du nur einmal im Jahr dahingegangen bist.
Genau. Das hab ich glaub ich auch gelesen. Und bei vielen von diesen Dingern ist es halt so, dass es gibt so ein Don't Ask, Don't Tell zwischen den Nachbarn. Natürlich, weil die alle irgendwie... Selbst wenn sie mal jemanden Handschellen da reinbringen müssen, ist es vollkommen okay, das gilt halt nur als Kinky, ne? Das ist halt so. Und wenn sie dann mal jemanden hatten, der dann aufmerksam wurde, also der dann sich irgendwie bei den Behörden, da gehen komische Dinge vor, dann haben sie den halt rekrutiert.
Der Mann hat gute observationsfähigkeit.
Meistens die Frau, dann haben sie halt als Watcher für diese Apartmentanlage, wo sie dann ihre Wohnung hatten, rekrutiert.
Super. Na ich wollte auch noch kurz ein kleines Buch placken, weil wir jetzt gerade bei MKUltra waren. Und wir haben ja erzählt, es geht zurück auf Manchurian Candidate, aber es geht eben auch zurück auf so eine Massenpanik, dass die Chinesen und die Russen in der Lage sind, Leute umzuprogrammieren. Und man hat angenommen, das hätte mit irgendwelchen Drogen zu tun. Und dann habe ich mich mal gefragt, worauf geht denn das zurück, diese Idee, dass die Russen das können? Und ich habe neulich so ein Buch gelesen von Robert Kalten, wie heißt der? Chialdini. Ich habe es englisch gelesen, heißt Influence the Psychology of persuasion. Das ist eigentlich so ein Marketing Buch, wo es ein bisschen darum geht, also in der Anleitung erklärt er eher, er ist halt so ein Typ, der immer auf irgendwelche Sales-Dinger reinfällt und er hat dann mal angefangen zu forschen, warum das eigentlich so ist. Und da erzählt er unter anderem, nach dem Korea-Krieg, da gab es natürlich amerikanische Kriegsgefangene und es gab die einmal bei den Nordkoreanern, die haben halt, um Sachen rauszufinden, haben die die dann halt zusammengeschlagen und gefoltert. Und es gab es bei den Chinesen und die haben die halt zivil behandelt, haben die ordentlich behandelt und haben aber so Spielchen mit ihnen gespielt. Also haben zum Beispiel Sachen gemacht, wie einen psychologischen Trick benutzt haben gesagt, hier, also du würdest doch zustimmen, in den USA ist nicht alles perfekt. So und dann stimmen sie da erst mal zu. Und dann immer so kleine Incremente gemacht. So ja, also an der Stelle im Kommunismus, das funktioniert doch auch ganz gut. Und am Ende sind da Aussagen rausgekommen. Also es gab dann auch so Sachen wie, du konntest ein Essay schreiben, über was halt in Amerika irgendwie gut oder nicht so gut ist. Und dann haben sie da irgendwie ausgelobt. Irgendwie gab es einen Apfel oder einen lächerlichen Preis. Gab es zu gewinnen, aber es gab ihn halt zu gewinnen. Für dein Essay. Und da haben halt alle irgendwie mitgemacht. Also der psychologische Trick an der Stelle ist, dass du das selbst aufschreibst und damit machst du es dir zu eigen. Ob du dich jetzt geglaubt hast oder nicht. Und wenn du dafür keine, also wenn du eine richtige Belohnung kriegst dafür, dann kannst du vor dir selbst das wegleugnen und sagen, ich hab's für die Belohnung gemacht. Aber wenn du nur was total winziges kriegst, wie irgendwie ein Apfel oder so, dann funktioniert es nicht mehr. Das heißt, der Trick war quasi, auf mehreren psychologischen Ebenen haben sie die Leute dazu gebracht, dass sie Sachen committet haben, auf Papier geschrieben haben. So ich finde dieses und jenes. Und als die Amis dann die zurückkehrenden Kriegsgefangene befragt haben, dann kamen da Äußerungen raus, wo es mich nicht wundert, dass die Amis Panik geschoben haben. Die haben dann so Sachen gesagt wie ja, Kommunismus ist scheiße und funktioniert nicht in Amerika, aber für Asien ist es vielleicht gar nicht schlecht. Und das ist ja schon mal für jemand, der gerade in Krieg gegen den Kommunismus gezogen hat, eine barbarisch umgedrehte Aussage von dem, was er vorher gesagt hätte. Also das heißt, als die Amis ihre Kriegsgefangenen aus China zurückgekriegt haben, haben die plötzlich irgendwie die Hälfte von denen war plötzlich also nicht offen pro-kommunistisch, aber bei weitem nicht mehr antikommunistisch wie vorher. Und da haben die Amis sich tierisch in die Hosen gemacht und haben halt gesagt, naja, dann müssen wir jetzt hier mal, das brauchen wir auch, das müssen wir auch machen. Und deswegen haben sie halt gesagt, naja, das müssen Drogen sein, weil die konnten sich halt nicht vorstellen. Die Psychologieforschung war bei weitem noch nicht weit genug, um diese Art von Sachen erklären zu können. Und das war in den 50er Jahren, das war so 53, 54. Und da ist auch dann Mk-Alpha losgetreten worden. Als gegenreaktion sozusagen. Erstens, wir müssen unsere eigenen Leute impfen, damit sie gegen sowas, gegen die Wahrheitsdrogen der Russen. Das war überhaupt die nächste Sache. Die Chinesen können das gar nicht, das müssen die Russen sein.
Verstehe, ja.
Das kann gar nicht sein, das muss irgendwie Special-Technologie der Russen sein. Das sind bestimmt Drogen und dann machen wir jetzt mal mit LSD was dagegen. Also das war quasi der Hintergrund. Und das ist, liest sich wirklich, wirklich beeindruckend, was die Chinesen geschafft haben, den amerikanischen Soldaten an Äußerungen abzuringen. Ja, mit eigentlich simplen psychologischen Tricks. Also das hat mich auch sehr beeindruckt. Und ich meine, man sieht an der Stelle, dass die Gefahr eigentlich uns alle betrifft, wenn wir irgendwas sehen, dann überzureagieren und auch in Demokratien so was wie die Geheimdienste loszutreten, der am Ende nicht kontrollierbar ist. Das ist halt auch eine der großen lektionen an der Stelle.
Diese Nicht-Kontrollierbarkeit von Geheimdiensten ist ja immer sozusagen die Grundeigenschaft. Der versucht zu sagen, wir müssen so geheim sein, dass selbst die Politiker, die wir kontrollieren, denen natürlich auch nichts anvertrauen kann. Also die Politiker, die den Geheimdienst kontrollieren sollten.
Wir können vielleicht kurz erklären, wie das in Deutschland funktioniert.
In Deutschland gibt es halt die...
Parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium heißt das jetzt.
kommissionen hieß es früher, ne?
Ja, PKK, aber da ist eine andere organisation, gibt es sich auch PKK.
Hat auch mit Geheimdiensten zu tun.
Man hat das dann, wenn es so zu viele Verwechslungen gibt, vielleicht mal hier Targeting.
Das sind Politiker, die speziell in diese kommission nicht gewählt, sondern entsandt werden von den Parteien.
Ja, also die Sache hat auch wieder mit der CIA zu tun. Die CIA, die lief ja auch relativ schnell aus dem Urude. Da gab es schon relativ früh in den USA parlamentarische Bestrebungen, diese Vereine an die Kandare zu nehmen. Diese Ellen Dulles, den wir vorhin erwähnt haben, der hat diese kommission regelmäßig eingeseift. Der muss also ein ziemlich guter Kommunikator gewesen sein, war auch ein Gesellschaftslöwe. Immer, wenn die dann was von wollten, dann ach ja, ja und so. Der hatte um den Finger gewickelt und das waren alles Papiertiger. Und der hat aber immer einen tierischen Schiss davor gehabt, dass diese Kontrollgremien mal irgendwann mächtig wurden. Und das Modell hat man in Deutschland eben auch übernommen. In Westdeutschland, was da stand, wurde der geheimnisnicht kontrolliert parlamentarisch. Aber hier auch nicht wirklich, denn es sind ganz einfach so, ich glaube, fünf Leute oder wie? Es ist jetzt spekulierend. Weiß es jemand? Wie groß die PKG ist? Es sind jedenfalls nur sehr überschaubare.
Und vor allem dürfen die keinem was erzählen davon, was sie da sehen, auch nicht ihren Kollegen.
Genau.
Und damit ist es natürlich eine Luftnummer.
Und vor allen Dingen, man erzählt ihnen, man zeigt ihnen das, was sie sehen sollen. Sie können es ja nicht überprüfen. Und jemand hat mal gesagt, man hält sie wie Pilze. Das heißt, man hält sie im Dunkeln und füttert sie mit Scheiße.
Also es gab da mal diese lustige Geschichte, wie ich glaube Ströbele war. Der sitzt für die Grünen in dieser kommission.
Was ein Riesen-Eck war, weil damals früher Grünen und so nicht Linker und Kronisten waren.
Also elf Mitglieder hat er.
Ich war mit fünf ganz gut genug.
Fast ja, also vier CDU-CSU, drei SPD, zwei FDP. Ströbele für die Grünen und Neskovitsch für die Linken.
Ist Neskovitsch jetzt wieder drin?
Also zumindest steht es in der Wikipedia im Jahre 2000.
Ah, dann muss es stimmen.
Wikipedia stimmt eben.
Ja, im Januar 2010 wurde Neskovitsch mit einer namentlichen Abstimmung mit 320 Jahren, 2629 wieder in das Kontrollgremium gewählt.
Ja, da gab es doch so ein Problem mit dem Jahr, wo er erst nicht gewählt wurde.
Wo er zuerst nicht bestätigt wird.
Ach so, ok.
Ja, wegen irgendwelcher Fristen nicht einhandeln, das ist einfach groß.
Also Neskovitsch ist aber der anscheinend Erste, der den Job wirklich richtig ernst nimmt.
Neskovitsch hat doch sich den Spaß gemacht, mal ein Praktikum, mal ein BND gemacht.
Ein paar Wochen hat er zugebracht und sich Dinge zeigen lassen. Also Neskovitsch muss dazu sagen, ist jetzt nicht irgendein Hallodri, sondern der ist immer Berichter am BGH gewesen und als Jurist absolut anerkannt. Er sitzt halt für die Linke, er ist nicht Mitglied, er ist parteilos, aber die Linke entsendet ihn und der Mann ist halt wirklich gut. Und der hat sich dann wirklich zeigen lassen, mit welchen Technologien der arbeiten hat. Er hat gesagt, er hat als Schweigepflicht, das nimmt er auch ernst. Aber was er da gesehen hat an Technologien, hätte ihm nicht gefallen. Und das stimmt ja schon mal ein bisschen bedenklich, ne? Gut, okay.
Also es gab mal einen Ansatz, um Geheimdienste wirklich zu kontrollieren. Das war die church-kommission. Und das ist entstanden nach Watergate. Denn da ist auch dem letzten idioten aufgefallen, Der Vietnamkrieg war gerade sehr, sehr unpopulär. Der Mega-Fail, genau. Und das ist ja auch stattgefunden durch fehlinformationen, die unter Angriff von der CIA gedeckt wurden. Insofern, da war also Geheimdienste unpopulär.
Ja und vor allen Dingen, es kam halt raus, dass eben die CIA Castro ermorden wollte und das also Amerikaner schockierend Mordagenten da rumsenden und so und so. Das war also für die amerikanische Bevölkerung doch ein bisschen viel und da gab es dann die church-kommission und die pike-kommission. Und da hat man dann sogar eigens ein Gesetz erlassen, das es Amerikanern verbietet, fremde Staatschefs zu töten.
Naja, was sie... Stimmt, Staatschefs dürfen sie immer noch nicht, aber die andere Leute dürfen sie per Executive Order.
Das ist jetzt was sehr Relatives.
Das sind halt enemy combatants.
Auf den Saddam hatten sie ja durchaus Cruise Missiles angesetzt. Weil sie dachten, er ist in diesem Restaurant. Also so ganz ernst nimmt man das wohl irgendwann nicht mehr, ne?
Na Moment, das ist ja auch die CIA, ne?
Ja, gut.
Also die Cruise Missiles kamen ja nicht von der CIA, sondern es ist ja eine militäroperation gegen den Quaitli-Stadt.
Interessant ist, was sie heute tun würden.
Gegen wen sich dieses Gesetz alles richtet.
Heute würden sie da wahrscheinlich einen Predator nehmen mit Hellfires.
Und das ist aber die CIA. Also was heißt CIA? Ich meine der amerikanische Geheimdienst operiert die Dinge.
Ja, so was wollte ich noch erzählen. Eigentlich sind wir so gut wie am Ende. Ich hab hier noch zwei.
Nein, nein, nein, die Remote Viewers.
Ach ja, die Double Viewers.
Ich hatte vorhin eine tolle Überleitung gehabt. Und zwar von MK-Altra. Da hatte man damals schon eben hell sehr engagiert. Da ist der Papier damit angefangen. Man hatte hell sehr engagiert und getestet. Und John Mulholland, dieser Zauberkünstler, sollte also auch evaluieren, ob diese Leute mit Tricks arbeiten oder ob sie überhaupt irgendwie Treffer landen und so. Und er war dann eher der Meinung, das ist wohl alles Bullshit. Ja. Und man hat das Programm damals also nicht weiter verfolgt. Dann aber Ende der 70er Jahre oder während der 70er Jahre ist ja dieser ganze esoterische Boom aufgekommen. Tark und Patov, das waren also zwei Parapsychologen, die haben ein Buch geschrieben, das nannte sich Mind Research, Scientists Look at Psychic Abilities. Auf Deutsch ist es rausgekommen, jeder hat den sechsten Sinn. Das waren übrigens die beiden.
Das war richtig scheiße populär, das Buch.
Ja, und das waren die beiden Leute, die einen gewissen Uri Gellner über mehrere Wochen lang in einem Labor getestet haben und dann zum Schluss gekommen sind, dass seine Fähigkeiten echt seien. Pass auf, du sitzt neben seinem Anwalt vor.
Oh, der Tisch biegt sich hier gerade. Aber naja, gut.
Also jedenfalls, dieses Buch hat ein gewisser Lieutenant Fred Holmes Edwater in die Hand gekriegt. Das war ein Abwehrspezialist, auch gerade Armies Missile Research and Development Command, also dieser Raketenabwehrgeschichten. Und der hat gesagt, Mensch, wenn die Russen das jetzt können, ja, da können wir unsere Geheimnisse nicht mehr schützen, wenn die ja auch den sechsten Sinn haben.
Ja, genau, so furchtbar.
Und dann müssen wir rausfinden, was gibt es jetzt wirklich oder nicht? Und dann hat dieser Mensch es geschafft, Leute in der Geheimniskommunity davon zu überzeugen, dass jetzt eine Einheit aufgebaut wird von Psychic Spies. Ja, also Leute, die ein paar psychologische Fähigkeiten haben. Das waren dann die Remote Viewers. Die haben also fast 20 Jahre lang, hat die Armee eine Handvoll Soldaten beschäftigt, die eben einfach nur versucht haben, durch konzentration herauszufinden, was so auf der Welt passiert. Denen haben die also Koordinaten gegeben. Sag mir mal, was da ist.
Vielleicht ist das mit den Satellitenbildern fanglich.
Ja, genau. Und das tragische war, die haben also immer dann Anfragen gekriegt von allen möglichen Militärdienststellen und so weiter. Und dann haben die Antworten gegeben. Aber weil das ja alles so ultra geheim war, haben die nie ein Feedback gekriegt, ob es richtig lag. Und es gab immer mal wieder so Gemurmel von, hey, was habt ihr da für Komiker da eben? Das heißt, diese Einheiten wurden immer wieder dicht gemacht. Dann fand sich in der Community eine andere Geheimdienststelle, die diese Remote-Views übernommen haben.
Das waren immer dieselbe Einheit, aber das ist halt von anderen.
Genau, so ungefähr wie so eine Wanderniere. Durch die Dienste diffundiert. Bei der NSA waren sie auch mal. Bei Inscom waren sie. Der General Stablebine war der Commander von Inscom. Der war sowieso schon immer ein bisschen wunderlich. Er war auch ein riesiger Uwe-Geller-Fan.
Die haben alle eine Weise, oder?
Das ist der Typ, der glaubte, er könnte durch konzentration die Materie durchdringen. Er hat sich vor eine Wand gestellt, konzentriert, nahm Anlauf und ist an die Wand geknallt.
Weil er durchlaufen wollte?
Ja, weil er durchlaufen wollte. Weil, ehrlich gesagt, die Atome sind jetzt zu 99 Prozent, bestehen die auch aus nichts, also völlig klar.
Da muss eigentlich nur seine Teilchen so synchronisieren, dass man gerade durchpasst.
Ich meine, Inscom ist der militärische Arm der NSA hier. Also es ist nicht, da hat einige tausend Leute unter sich gehabt. Da gibt es jetzt diesen Film The Man Who Stare at God's. Und da wird also dieser Stabilizer gezeigt.
Das ist der Offensivarm der Remote Viewing.
Und bei dem Film, es stimmt die Hälfte. Ja, es gibt also ein Sachbuch von John Ronson, das eben als Ausgang für diesen Film genommen wurde. Die Handlung haben sie jetzt in die Jetztzeit verlegt, also Irakkrieg und so weiter. Das war eher der Vietnamkrieg, der damals noch virulent war. Aber es gab wirklich diesen General, der an die Wand gerannt ist und sich eine blutige Nase geholt hat und ganz frustriert war.
Und seine Einheit hat tatsächlich, also da kommt der Titel her, versucht, Ziegen tot zu starren.
Genau.
Also die haben sich hingestellt und haben gesagt, du stirbst gleich, böser Blick. Wie im Mittelalter, böser Blick, gleich stirbt. Die kriegt einen Herzinfarkt.
Und die waren auch überzeugt, dass sie das konnten.
Irgendwann wird das funktionieren. Wenn wir das noch lange noch machen, dann funktioniert das irgendwann. Was ja auch stimmt, irgendwann gibt es Altersschwäche.
Jedenfalls, diese Leute wurden auch alle möglichen Seminare geschickt, haben auch in diesen Tanks gelegen, wo sie ohne Sinneseindrücke irgendwie...
Das hat übrigens einen anderen Hintergrund. Das hat mit Folterforschung zu tun. Da werden wir auch mal eine Sendung machen.
Ja, aber jetzt nicht in dem Zusammenhang. Ja. Ohne mich. Es gibt ja immer bei dem... Bei NORAD gibt es ja immer einmal im Jahr diesen Gag, dass sie also sagen, der Weihnachtsmann kommt. Und dann haben diese Psychic Spies sich irgendwann einen Scherz mit einem erlaubt, das war so einer, der wohl der Durchgeknallteste war. Also war ein UFO-Fan und so weiter, hat auch irgendwie Bücher über biblische Themen geschrieben. Also sehr, sehr merkwürdig der Typ. Und naja, jedenfalls, dem haben sie gesagt, oh, ich empfange was, ich empfange was, es kommt über den Nordpol, es leuchtet rot.
Der Weihnachtsmann.
Ja genau, es sollte der Weihnachtsmann sein. Aber der andere Kollege, der hat es also völlig ernst genommen und wollte schon Atomalarm auslösen. Das heißt also, durch so einen Blödsinn wäre möglicherweise ein Hühnerstall geweckt worden. Irre.
Und es ist ja nicht nur die Dienst, die total durchgeknallt sind. Also ich hab hier noch so eine andere Anlehnung, die wurde immer rausgekramt, nur um mal zu zeigen, wie schlimm ich meine. Also erstmal, die erste Geschichte ist, dass die Briten nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ernsthaft überlegt haben, ob sie nicht ein paar Atombomben im Rhein versinken. Und die Idee war, wenn die Russen kommen, naja, wenn sie Ostdeutschland haben sie ja eh schon, wenn sie irgendwie bis zum Rhein kommen, naja gut, dann haben sie das halt. Und dann zünden wir die Bomben, damit sie nicht Frankreich einnehmen. So, das war die Idee. Also die hätten einfach mal komplett Deutschland als Kollateralschaden.
So war der Plan.
Da mussten irgendwie diese Bomben, die mussten irgendwie warm gehalten werden. Und da war eben ein Patent, dass also da irgendwie Vögel da drauf angesiedelt werden, die also da rumbrüten. Und diese Tierwärme hätte also ausgereicht, die technischen Details kenne ich nicht, aber da kann man ein bisschen zugucken, da findet man was. Es gab allerdings auch eine amerikanische Variante von diesem Plan. Bei den Briten war sie die Strategie der verbrannten Erde, dass man also Deutschland an der Stelle einfach hätte hochgelassen, atomar verseucht, edgy badgy, wenn das nicht durchgeht, dann geht das auch nicht. Und die Amerikaner hatten entlang der Ostgrenze Einrichtungen vorgesehen, in die man transportable Atombomben reinstellen wollte und wenn die Russen kommen, dann lässt man ein paar herkommen und dann lässt man das Ding platzen, sodass da also ein nuklear verseuchter Korridor gewesen wäre, der dann eben Ost- und Westdeutschland voneinander gespaltet hätte.
Lustigerweise haben die Russen ja einen ähnlichen Plan gehabt, wenn die Amis kommen, dann hätten sie irgendwie über das die DDR verstrahlt oder irgendwie so ein Ding.
Also die hätten dann so in beiden Fällen dran geglaubt.
Die Russen, also der Plan der Service sah ja vor, dass egal was kommt, wenn es also nicht einen All-out-Nuklear-Austausch gibt, so schnell wie möglich, so tief wie möglich in den Westen vorzudringen. Also um halt selbst, wenn dann Nuklear passiert, dass der möglichst weit wegfährt, also was denn dann passiert. Und die Gegenstrategie des Westens war dann halt diese Atommin, die in verschiedensten Ausführungen dann daherkam. Ich weiß nicht, was ich noch dran erinnere. Also davon gab es auch die konventionelle Variante. Was ich noch dran erinnere, wenn man bei Helmstedt rübergefahren ist, vom Osten in den Westen, dann gab es auf der Autobahn so eine Zickzacklinie von Gullideckeln, das waren die Löcher für die Minen.
atomic-demonstration-mines.
Dafür gab es die konventionelle Variante, die war auch offiziell den Leuten, die diese Dinger betreuen sollten, bekannt.
Walmänner.
Genau, die Walmeisterminen, die auch in den Brücken und so rein sollten. Aber da gab es eben diese Dinger, die in diese Gullis sollten. Und dafür gab es halt präzise auch da passend halt auch eine Nuklearvariante, um halt die sowjetischen Panzerhorden aufzuhalten, die sie erwartet haben. Genau, dann halt durch den Magdeburger Tiefebene.
Ja, es gab halt noch das kleine Problem, dass eben, egal wie, es hätte einige hunderttausend Deutsche, Westdeutsche, das Leben gekostet.
Ja gut, aber darauf, wenn Krieg ist, ja.
Das wäre auch sowieso passieren. Und wiederum die des Sowjets haben denn, um dem wiederum vorzubeugen, eigene Spätznazeinheiten ausgebildet, die DDR übrigens auch, die hat Fernaufklärer ausgebildet, um genau präzise diese Minendepots zu sprengen oder zu besetzen und diese, die haben dann auch so spezielle Vorrichtungen gebaut, um diese Gullis unbruchbar zu machen, sodass sie da diese Minen gar nicht reichen.
Zuschweißen oder wie?
Nee, es war so ein elaboriertes Zusprengen. Nee, elaboriertes Zusprengen halt und dafür zu sorgen, dass, wenn dann so kleine Teams, die sie dann halt hinter die Grenze geschickt hätten, um präzise genau dafür zu sorgen, dass an den neurologischen Punkten, also zum Beispiel auch an den Rheinbrücken sind ja auch die superneurologischen Punkte, für einen tiefen Vorstoß und an diversen Talsperren, Staudämmen und so, wo halt solche Sprenglöcher vorgesehen worden haben, die an Holzmodellen tatsächlich spezifisch geübt, halt bestimmte Bauwerke zu schützen, also vor der Sprengung und diese Bunker im Wald zu finden und rechtzeitig die hochzunehmen. Also da gab es dann, ich weiß nicht ob es dagegen dann wieder noch einen Counter gab, ich vermute mal schon, aber das der...
Ich weiß dafür, eine Produktivität vernichtet wurde für diese ganzen Spielereien. Also ich habe hier noch ein besonders schönes Beispiel, finde ich, und zwar war das zur Nixon-Zeit, da war ja Kissinger der Berater und der Chefstrateg der Amis und es ging, es war 1969, der Vietnamkrieg tobte und Nixon wollte den weghaben, aber sie konnten nicht aufgeben. Sie mussten ihr Gesicht warnen und dann haben sie sich, die Theorie an der Stelle war, dass die Russen die Nordvietnamesen versorgen und wenn man jetzt den Russen dazu kriegen könnte, dass er aufhört Vietnam Rückendeckung zu geben, dann würden die schon aufgeben. Und dann haben sie überlegt, na wie können wir denn die Russen überreden und haben Spieletheorie angewendet und haben sich überlegt, also wenn wir jetzt einfach mit einem Atomschlag drohen und die Russen glauben wir sind rational, dann wissen die, dass wir nicht schießen können. Deswegen müssen wir simulieren, dass Nixon durchgedreht ist. Und sie haben, es nennt sich Mad Man Strategy. Genau. Und was sie gemacht haben, ist, dass sie 18 atomar bewaffnete Bomber Richtung Moskau losgeschickt haben, mit scharfen Bomben drin. Und sie haben dafür gesorgt, dass die Russen wissen, dass die da drin sind und dass die unterwegs sind. Und dann haben sie quasi ein paar unterlinks, irgendwie so niedrige Ränge, also nicht Nixon selbst, sondern niedrige Ränge haben dann bei den Russen angerufen und gesagt, übrigens diese Bomber, der Nixon ist durchgeknallt und wenn er jetzt nicht sofort einlenkt, können wir den auch nicht mehr aufhalten. So und die Theorie war also, dass die Russen dann sagen, es hätte wahrscheinlich mit Reagan besser geklappt als mit dem Nixon. Aber ich meine, so nahe waren wir alle an der Vernichtung, dass so eine Dinger noch. Ja, mehrfach. Und es gibt da noch so ein paar Details, wie zum Beispiel, dass man von außen so ein Flugzeug, so ein Bomber ansehen kann, ob die jetzt beladen sind oder nicht mit den Bomben. Denn wenn eine Bombe drin ist, ist der schwerer und verbraucht sein Sprit schneller. Und dadurch wird er leichter. Und die Geschwindigkeitsveränderung ist messbar. Das heißt, die wussten, also die Russen wussten, dass die da beladen sind. Genau. Und das ist so ausgegangen, dass die Russen glaubwürdig versichern konnten, dass sie den Nordvierten gar nicht zurückpfeifen können, selbst wenn sie wollten. Und dann ist der Bluff der Amis aufgeflogen. Aber also überlegt euch mal, was für ein Druck die da aufgebaut haben. Unglaubliche Geschichten. Und die zweite Sache, die ich noch ansprechen wollte, sind nicht nur die Dienste, die immer total inkompetent sind, sondern es gibt noch so eine Geschichte aus der JFK-Zeit zur Kuba-Krise. Und zwar, das kommt aus dem Buch Legacy of Ashes, was ich übrigens empfehlen kann. Da geht es um die CIA-Historie. Und in dieser Geschichte geht es darum, dass die JFK-Kabinett hat sich unterhalten, also JFK mit seinen Generälen haben sich darüber unterhalten, wieso die Russen dann jetzt auf Kuba Atomraketen stationieren. Und da hat JFK dann so gefragt, ja, das versteht ihr ja gar nicht, warum machen die denn so was? Das müssen die doch wissen, dass wir das als Angriff wählten. Und das wäre ja so, als wenn wir Raketen in der Türkei stationieren. Und darauf war so zehn Sekunden peinliches Schweigen in dem Raum. Und dann meinte jemand, Herr Präsident, wir haben Raketen in der Türkei stationiert. Also ich mein, solche Leute haben dieses Land regiert. Unglaublich, unglaublich. Und dann geht es dann noch so weiter, dass die, also als die die optionen verhandelt haben, was sie denn jetzt tun könnten in dieser Missile Crisis, da war Verhandeln überhaupt nicht auf der Liste. Da gab es so drei, viele Möglichkeiten. Ja, wir können hier eine invasion machen, wir können da Newbs drauf werfen, wir können dieses, jedes machen. Auch die Überlegung, eine Blockade zu machen, ist erst nachträglich reingekommen. Also die ursprüngliche Planung hat nur überlegt, wie wir jetzt am besten angreifen. Also das ist ein Wunder, dass wir überhaupt noch leben. Bei aller Geheimdienst-Inkompetenz und bei aller Politiker-Inkompetenz am Ende haben wir immer noch Glück auch.
Naja und tatsächlich ein paar Leute an den richtigen Stellen, die zur richtigen Zeit gesagt haben, wir glauben mal lieber nicht daran, was jetzt hier irgendwie den Bildschirm schlimmer hat.
Mein persönlicher Held ist natürlich Petrov. Und der hat noch eine Geschichte erzählt, die vielleicht ein guter Schluss ist. Und zwar, die hatten da tatsächlich einen roten Knopf stehen und auf der Amateur da irgendwie draufgelötet. Und niemand wusste so genau, was es damit auf sich hat. Und es gab immer so die Legende, dass es jetzt vielleicht sogar eine Möglichkeit, den Vergeltungsschlag auszulösen. Und wie auch immer.
Das würde man ja auch annehmen, wenn man da sitzt.
Der Knopf sah auch wichtig aus, war auch durch so ein Gassturz irgendwie drüber oder so. Don't press any button. Und dann hat sich der Petroff den aber irgendwann mal angeguckt und hat festgestellt, dass da die Drähte von einem Ding nirgendwo hinführen. Dieser rote Knopf war eine Art Trappe, war eine Art Zauberkasten. Denn irgendwelche Psychologen hatten rausgefunden, dass ein einzelner Mensch diese Entscheidung gar nicht... Also erst mal, einem einzelnen Menschen würde diese Entscheidung nicht übertragen worden.
Aber selbst wenn du es tust, niemand würde auf diesen Knopf drücken?
Ja, zumindest sehr wenig Leute würden es wirklich tun.
Das ist doch gut so.
Das heißt also, der rote Knopf war in dem Fall ein Zauberkasten.
Den gab es sozusagen gar nicht, ja. Den Knopf schon.
Also wir haben ja auch so einen Knopf hier im Klub. Der macht auch nichts weiter.
Ich bin ja immer noch Anhänger der Theorie, dass der dafür da ist, falls irgendjemand mal so eine Kommandozentrale besetzt, um jetzt den Weltuntergang auszulösen, dass für den denn so ein Knopf da ist.
Damit der irgendwas zum draufdrücken hat. Eigentlich braucht man noch so eine simulation, so wie, ja, hier sind abgeschossen.
Na gut.
Damit kommen wir mal zum Ende. Wir haben schon über zwei Stunden hier verpaten.
Wir sind jetzt schon doch deutlich ein sehr langer Podcast geworden. Sehr schön. Herzlichen Dank fürs Zuhören. Auch wenn es ein etwas wildes Springen sich fürchtet, wird eigentlich eine der längsten Linklisten, die wir jemals zusammen compilert haben.
Ich glaube gar nicht, so viele Links haben wir gar nicht.
Diverse Bücherempfehlungen werden auch dabei sein, die durchaus alle die Lektüre lohnen. Denn noch herzlichen Dank an Markus Kumpa, für das ich hier sein dürfte.
Eine coole aktion.
Ansonsten wie immer noch der Hinweis auf den Flatter-Button, obwohl wir gerade noch nicht mehr so richtig wissen, was wir mit dem Geld zahlen.
Wir kaufen erstmal ein Headset für den nächsten Gast. Wir haben jetzt hier gerade so eine wüste ghetto-installation mit einem Mikrofon, was wir hier an einem Koffer befestigt haben, damit es ungefähr nicht so dreh ist.
Es stimmt, genau. Wir hoffen, dass das Markus nicht zu seltsam klingt im endgültigen Mix und damit er beim nächsten Mal genauso toll klingt, wie wir alle Koffer nach Gäste-Headsets ahnen. Ja, wenn er auf den Flatter-Knopf drücken wollt, dann freuen wir uns natürlich. Ansonsten...
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und Durchhalten.
Genau, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.